the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the second leg of the 2022 grand chess
tour started off with a bang at the
super bed rapid and blitz in warsaw
poland players were excited to show off
their rapid form in the faster time
control with nearly every game ending
decisively players took their wins and
lumps in stride all except former world
champion vishwanathan anand who insisted
on crushing everyone he battled winning
all three of his games the legendary
veteran has set the pace can anyone
catch him day two of fast-paced jess
coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day two of the
super bed rapid and blitz hosted here in
warsaw poland we start a day in front of
the gorgeous saxon gardens as we are
getting ready for the players to arrive
they had enough time to adjust to the
requirements of rapid and blitz and are
ready for another action-packed day
let's go to the studio and start today's
round with yasser peter and alejandra
fantastic footage of the springtime in
the polish capital as we welcome you to
day two of the super
blitz in warsaw poland the second stop
of the 2022 granchester
welcome and good morning i'm peter
switler with me is yasaseeravan peter as
always a great pleasure to be with you
and and and alejandro to call all the
action yesterday was so much fun hello
everyone and welcome to our show day one
will go down as a perfect day for one
this one-a-thon anand as the tiger of
madras can still roar
peter
give us our current standings after day
one of action very very exciting day
yesterday and we assume the same will
happen today absolutely this is a bit of
a preview of our format with vishy there
on top after three games on six points
meaning that you get as you can see on
your screen two points per win
uh and he is a full two points ahead in
front of his nearest pursuers and those
include two of the candidates uh fabian
young christian of duda and lewandan
also on four points uh and then a bunch
of people on 50
and the two youngsters uh bringing up
the rio there both had a difficult day
yesterday absolutely and there for mac
peter
uh the format is basically three round
robins uh rolled into one first uh r10
players will play a rapid round robin
nine rounds of uh 25 plus 10 rapid games
and then on sunday and monday they will
play uh two full blitz round robins uh
or five plus two draw four is not
allowed uh as with with the same uh as
in classical and uh you get double the
points for four rockets so those nine
games uh assume additional importance
because of that absolutely and
day ones in the history books what's our
remaining schedule uh we will have three
more rounds of rapid today three more
rounds of rapid on saturday and then
nine rounds of blitz on both sunday and
monday uh with playoffs if necessary are
happening immediately after the last
round finishes on monday
wonderful and alejandro good to see you
my friend in studio
what a day we had yesterday so many
decisive games alejandro good morning
yasser good morning peter of course
we're here early in the studio in st
louis and yesterday was quite a doozy of
course in bucharest we had a lot of
action and a lot of fights but some of
those days we just had one decisive game
out of five classical games in rapid no
such thing take a look at how we started
off in warsaw with 11 out of the first
15 games being decisive we had a victor
in every single one of them about 73
percent of the games finished with
somebody winning and let's take a look
also at the players by their age and it
almost looks like it's the standings as
vishyanan and lavona ronian are there
near the top and the youngsters the
upcoming players the wildcards
chefchenko and gabrielescu with only 19
years of age and significant age gap
between them and the rest of the field
well they're having some trouble here in
the event starting out with only half a
point out of their first six games
certainly with some problems is youth
against experience in this tournament
and remember we have
this as a part of the grand chess tour
we already have one tournament in the
books as mvl took down the price in
bucharest but he split the gct points we
had a three-way tie for first and in
this tournament we have four of the
players participating wesley so levon
adonian fabiano carona and richard
rapport who really needs to make a
comeback in these tournaments if he
wants to have a shot at taking the grand
chess tour title for himself here's a
person that is no stranger at taking the
title our defending gct champion wesley
so started a little tepid i would say in
warsaw but did take advantage of kiril
shevchenko's fighting spirit who well
left it down a pawn early in a rookie
one berlin but wesley not a stranger to
winning any of these events let's take a
look at who he is facing as we go to
warsaw with anastasia and christian who
have the key pairings for the day
welcome back everybody to day two of the
super bat a rapid blitz from location
here in warsaw poland i am your host to
give you all the live updates of the
action grand master christian kirilla
alongside my co-host woman grandmaster
anastasia carlovich anastasia yesterday
we had an amazing day filled with
exciting chess but the story of the day
has to be the following on the rise of
vichy anand talk to me for a second what
games do you have your eyes set on for
today's match-ups yeah it's been a
really great day and we had chance to
witness it to in the plane venue which
is just next to the studio and it was a
really great pleasure to see wishiwin in
all those games and he's in a good shape
and a good mood of course after the day
one but today my eyes will be on his
game against uh ukrainian player kirill
shivchenko who has his chance today to
prove that he still
is able to play with against those
strong guys you know and today he will
play and he'll have his chance he's a
brave ukrainian guy so let's see i think
he will try to do his best today what do
you think kristen let's see if the tiger
of madras will be able to continue he's
a roar that one is a big matchup indeed
i have my eyes set on on the battle
between the two poles radoslav vojtack
versus jan shishtav duda the five-time
polish champion just crowned polish
champion voitacek will be playing the
white pieces and we see they're head to
head is equal one win for radek one loss
and two draws of course this is only in
rapid chance they've played played
plenty of time in classical chess this
one is going to be an explosive affair
guys how about yourselves what games do
you have your eyes set on well thank you
anastasia thank you christian
uh those are going to be two very
exciting games indeed but let's take a
look at all of the pairings and then
i'll tell you my picks peter certainly
yeah up top there is a game uh where
anton karbov is white against
fabicaruana i'll stop right there yeah
that's my big that's going to be an
example
and i want to continue my plea that i i
issued you know desperately yesterday
that you know we abandoned all other
interviews and just interviewed antoine
corbin about every single game in the
tournament and also about non non-game
related stuff
and though yeah there he is there he is
the the man himself
looking
looking very dapper
or yeah did we get a haircut i'm not 100
sure i don't know how to tell her yeah
that's that's one way to describe it uh
and the rest of the parents because yeah
uh
richard rapport white against uh david
garvileski who so far hasn't
gotten any points at all had a very
tough day yesterday and will in general
have i think a very tough event because
he was he was basically thrown off of
deep end i think he got the invitation
maybe five days prior to the tournament
and this is very very difficult to
suddenly find himself preparing for for
a tournament of this magnitude agreed
i've already seen glimpses yesterday of
why he is considered to be a very
promising remaining youngster i think
he's a good player it's just a very
difficult sort of first first experience
of playing these guys
the the old polish duel uh
the guys in warsaw spoke about wesley
against levon would normally be marquis
match
essential game of the round but there is
so many exciting players in this field
that you you kind of glow so gloss over
it and vishay against uh characters
choice vishy the experience
nine-time world champion
of the swanathon anon
uh up against uh the youth yeah the
youths
and there we get a beautiful view of the
playing stage uh
certainly i can imagine
uh being in there in person you really
get the gravity of both the location it
is it is a very yeah
a very very beautiful venue to play and
yeah as you see on your screen this is
uh a theater inside the museum of the
history of polish jews
exactly
in bucharest we had a number of really
outstanding sportsmen who were making
the ceremonial first moves is that going
to be a tradition that they'll continue
in warsaw we had a we had a chess
official and
an active chess player to do the honors
yesterday apart from from gary doing i
think round one and then the president
of the polish aspirations
so
uh we don't exactly know who it will be
today we might have
have info sort of live together with you
because
it normally appears on our screen and
here we go yeah
we do have another guest of honor uh
choosing the the the old polish board
the secretary of state that's a very
prestigious minister
making d2 d4 and within a little
flourish yeah i mean and also a
move that is very you know clearly knows
what radix repertoire
is study this database yes
yes
well played sorry yeah well well played
and we round four
we do appear to have liftoff yes
absolutely
and i just
just so happen to have anton um korboff
versus fabio on my board and i do see
in english as there you see our
tournament leader of vichy in an open
sicilian yes it looks good
i think shivchenko plays the the
kashnikov it depends on which
the question now i think mainly is which
move order he chooses whether he wants
to allow the four knights or just go e5
straight away yeah we also have a beards
in in the old polish duel
which is quite
nice quite interesting yeah yeah i
i i love the perk by the way i mean i
was raised on it i had a lot of a lot of
wonderful wonderful games
with the perp but i do recognize it
it's
it's a little dicey
i've played i've played tons of it when
i was uh in my twenties and uh yeah i i
didn't even do that poorly it's just
that at some point once you once you get
to a certain level of a position
the fun kind of dissipates right
you no longer really get the positions
you play the opening for begin right
yeah
and also the fact is that white has such
a wide
variety of approaches
against and also my feelings got hurt
because i remember i played i played in
my first ever linares in 98 and then i
think in round two
potentially i played the beards against
vichy
and mig who in those times used to write
a column for
i think the week in chess he was writing
a column chess ninja yeah who yeah just
ninja wonderful wonderful guy i don't
see him often enough for my liking
uh he had a column where he introduced
the
uh i think the chicken chess index
and uh
uh i wasn't i don't like where this is
going yeah no no actually i mean if you
play the periods you really shouldn't be
on like that it shouldn't be that wasn't
the accusation but he did he did
immediately award me the jankiest
opening of the tournament award
and i was better by 15. i did lose the
game but i was better by move 15. and i
thought yeah i mean if this is what i
get i know abuse for trying to play
fighting openings wow wow i'll just go
back to playing my zaitsev's and
marshalls and things i'm going to keep
an eye on the perk defense the
all-polish derby but i want to switch it
over to you uh uh alejandro as we've got
especially nothing much happening we're
still waiting for the results of the
opening uh yeah shepchenko and vichy
they're going straight into a mainline
smashing cup with c3 i expect either
bishop g5 or castle or rook b8 one of
these moves that has become quite
popular throughout the many years uh in
the game that you guys were focusing on
actually the move bishop c4 is super
rare yes this game between erotic and
young christo run christoph
knight f6 seems to be like everybody's
choice in this position but
e6
i was not expecting uh dude to play the
move knight f6 just because i think he
wants to mix things up somehow so he
doesn't really want to go into normal
channel channels he plays the movie six
you're playing a french down a tempo
with d5 later what is your point here
after castling or do you go h4 this is
gonna be a fun one because i think the
players are gonna be straight out of
theory we know that radek loves this
theory but i think that duda is playing
really hard
uh not to fall into any kind of deep
theoretical i think he's just just gonna
play the hippo now right i mean having
gone d6 on e6 you're kind of supposed to
play the hippo now you're supposed to
spiritually play the hippo here the
hippo is where you bring your knights to
d7
and e7 and either b6 and bishop b7 or a6
bishop b5 and bishop b7 and as you say
or or 6 g5 96 and get made another king
yeah well well that's kind of like the
the black lion they're calling in these
days it's very hard to to keep up to
date with all of the naming of the
openings and i'm not even sure well the
hipster is easy
and this is one of those cases where
yeah
it's it's definitely one of those cases
where the english name for for the
opening is just much better than than
what i was thought to to use because
yeah it's called the uitel key the what
uh the uh there was a hungarian
international master i think who
pioneered it in sometime mid mid
previous century
and yeah it was never called the hippo
in in in my childhood if it had a name
at all it was called the uitelke which
you i mean your face says it all
on the topic of
the
uitalki yeah no i've known it as a hippo
since i was a kid me too yeah the
hippopotamus and it was really made
famous at least uh for americans when uh
petrosian essay did in the world
championship uh against basket i mean
like it just seems so strange to uh
probably such a cramped game probably a
must-win game i would say yeah i would
assume so as well
b7 b6 like i said uh bishop b7 knight e7
castles and you were mentioning peter
that black's approach can be you know
the suicidal h6 g5 knight g6 even though
somewhat shockingly it often is a lot
harder to refute than it looks precisely
because it's sort of like when white
tries to play e5 and take advantage of
is
better development first of all it's not
clear that you're better developed but
secondly
black could shut down the position with
d5 conversely if you try
the other one then comes the other
shutdown so it's this flexible approach
means that well you can't just force the
position open
and uh
which is why you you mentioned earlier
maybe a more concrete approach before
you had casted with h4h5p
alhamdus at h4 and i thought
uh he definitely with the king steel on
e1 including h4 and perhaps having said
that
black very clearly plays h6 in many of
these positions anyway and definitely
doesn't mind the h5 g5 the issue with
playing g5 for black in these types of
positions is it is that it invites h4
with the white pawn already on h5 your
structure on the king side there will be
a lot less
prone to getting blown up later so
i'm just putting some moves on the board
to demonstrate what you mean yeah like
if you do this yeah you get you get
immediately heated with h4 and g4 and
then
the thing starts collapsing but if white
actually
spends too tempting getting the pawn to
h5 and then you play g5 you're much
better off compared but yeah radical i
think is a very restrained player and
he's done he's done something else
altogether i can imagine uh michael
bassman for one gleefully playing g5 in
such a position
he might be losing no i think i think
i'm i'm taking this person with black
that's kind of i think i'm fine with it
exactly i played enough periods in my
childhood too right i could be quite
okay with this okay but instead yeah
radicanster plays knight g2
bishop b7 knight f1 which is an
indication that he wants to play kind of
a
spanish
type set up the bishop often returns to
d3
uh yeah another six played which is you
have to start yeah you have to start
asking yourself if you want to allow d65
i have a feeling if you play knight g3
here black might not mind actually just
responding with d5 straight away right
straight away or even including cast
well if you castle i definitely play
bishop d3 here i'm no longer going to be
allowing it i'm pretty sure that uh
quick question for you as we just get
into a position that looks like this
wouldn't you describe this as some kind
of an accelerated really low pass this
is a bra area but yeah but black you
know it's it's kind of a double-edged
sword because uh one of the issues black
often has in slow spanish structures is
that the pawn on b5 which will be there
by move like six in most cases right uh
would be somewhat weak and white could
play against it by
playing a4 and attacking it here it's on
b6 right so there is no weakness but
there's also much less scope for trying
to expand on the queen side like you
can't really play b5 c4 and knight c5 so
your knight on d7 is very cramped and i
think here black's position is a lot
more solid but there it's also a lot
more difficult to figure out what our
counterplay is here though okay okay
we'll leave it at that and
shoot it over to alejandro as
what game are you looking at there
alejandra
well we have the game between wesley saw
and lavone aronian of course we have to
take a look at this one but it is a
quiet type of catalan we've actually
seen this position several times over
the grand chess tours this one
specifically with lavonna ronan on the
black side of this structure where white
structure's a bit weak you have the c4
part and a2 pawn long-term weaknesses
but you can see the difference of
activity in the pieces this has been
reached at the 2700 level many many
times i think that black has only won
this position once
from the over 70 games that i have at
the grandmaster level peter i think you
know which one that is yeah
did i ever tell you the story of how i
got here how you got i was actually
wondering how you got to this position
it's it's kind of a funny story this
happened to me twice in my entire career
and this is the second time basically i
somehow won i think i was much worse
with the y this is the rapid type break
against fabi in the hunted 2011 world
cup the one that i ended up winning
and uh i
we made to some of the uneventful draws
in classical and then i won
some kind of a weirdly enough slab on
the white side i was slightly worse out
of the opening and then outplayed five a
bit
and i needed the draw in this game
and i like i spent the entire 10 minutes
between the games trying to figure out
which grundfeld he will play against me
didn't really settle on any kind of an
answer but still like greenfield is my
only opening
so it's like reading
yeah it's not really very relevant what
he does because i'm going to play the
grim field anyway
and i came to the board in this kind of
a dream state and he went before i went
knight f6 he went c4
and i kind of woke up from the dream
state in my e7 pawn in my hand
what seriously i'm not i'm not joking
about this oh like i
i just sort of up and i have i've
already touched it it's not like i'm
reaching for it it's in my hand
i have played some non-grinfeld openings
in my life but like seriously this was a
kind of an unpleasant shock
and i mean i put it on e6 because i mean
i i played the budapest as
a youngster but i'm not going to play
the budapest in a must-draw game against
fabi
and and this is how i played this
then you won and then you beat bobby
yeah i was something completely busted
okay
that's just that's hilarious that's very
very funny take it away alejandro what
happened next i'm gonna skip ahead
because we had a ton of moves and it's
rapid time control we do have to get to
all the games this is the position on
the board
there's still some pressure you have a
knight on c6 and it does look a little
dangerous still i don't think that black
has completely solved these issues but
the rook will come to c7 there is some
counter pressure on the pawn on b5 there
will be some tactics at some point
hopefully with a5 once the dino c6 is
not fully defended computers say zero
zero obviously i think that white is
preferable in this position but it does
seem like levon is doing just fine in
this one all right thank you for that i
just wanted to quickly switch to the
vichy a non-game uh as he's up against
kirill um
again a very very
theoretical duel still going on the move
h28 not at all right this bishop b6 move
is extremely real i wanted to say that
bishop g5's main movement
yeah both of them are the two main moves
and bishop
okay go ahead alejandro a very rare move
bishop e6 that's it it's been played
what 20 times out of the thousand
thousand thousands of games yeah and so
vishy uh very quickly said look
your bishop on g5 is a little awkward
it's kind of stuck and oftentimes it's
important that the bishop go
to g5 and patrols this diagonal i'm
going to stop you just i'm just going to
stop you i'm going to play also i think
an early example of uh how practical and
how how good vishy is at just making
those decisions because i'm pretty sure
he i mean he vishy is one of the people
who may have actually looked at bishop
physics at some point in his life but
probably not today right and you know
people are liable to like spend five
minutes trying to figure out what this
is wow yeah vishnu knows vishy knows
it's kind of sort of irrelevant and also
pointless and a waste of time and energy
so he just makes a move which generally
is going to be useful in every single
position like this and just goes from it
uh you know goes to you know next
question please yes because he knows
there will be like game doesn't end if
he doesn't make the best move in this
position exactly let's just make a move
and play exactly h4 again often times
this knight on c2
wants to uh support his colleague either
by knight c3 or knight before it's a
very logical move and if the bishop yeah
if the bishop is not on g5 tickling the
knight on e3 then you then the move h4
is very useful i mean the one question i
do have is maybe black has enough time
to take on d5 go knight t7 and d5 but
maybe you don't equalize even if you do
all that this is my big question because
85 you pretty much never worried with
black right this is the dream scenario
in pretty much every single swish nick
of position yeah you don't really want
to occupy d5 so you take with the queen
i go 97 and i go to 65 next move again
whichever square you choose like windy
yeah let's just go yeah right
and let's
93 or d1 or
yeah
i thought was maybe
actually maybe you can even make an
argument for long castling
weirdly
i played h4 yeah because we yeah we have
we have a pawn on h4 bishop g5 check is
not an issue here d5d4 becomes maybe
somewhat interesting actually i was
because i put my king yeah
i was going to suggest it's playable
even after d1 to be honest but wait a
minute okay so what what peter and i are
trying to avoid for black is a duel
where
i get to now yeah something like this
could be very unpleasant it's a very
powerful battering ram even at the cost
of an a2 pawn my my the white attack
might be too strong which is why d5d4 i
think is a very topical idea in these
types of positions but then you've got
to be yeah it takes takes a form
for me quite a bit yeah yes as
white looks to again i thought 9g6 but
g3 just covers everything so beautiful
discovers absolutely everything and then
we go e5 and we win exactly exactly
exactly yeah they actually played all of
this including queen d3 so with the
conversation we've had this has not been
wasted
a fruitful conversation very very i
wasn't sure but i i it felt to me that
this could be one way to justify having
played bishop e6 right but okay now
having said that if you don't play d5
that is going to be a very poor excuse
for a pawn on the other
and now is an interesting and
interesting moment in the game exactly
because we did look at rook d1 we did
look at castles but the other third
option
maybe this
i'm still going to four you know i'm
still going to
maybe uh
seems playable yeah i'm not sure i'm so
happy but it seems playable exactly it's
not like yeah okay i i completely agree
with that so i think castles by the way
is if you're talking about very very
ambitious yeah for me that's got to be
the most ambitious move rook d1 i wonder
if we can play castle's queen b6 but
maybe it's not great anyway yeah because
i think he takes d5 queen takes f2 f2 is
not that relevant and the ball on d5
will be i mean it gets the g6 and let's
say we go d7 yeah we go we go g6 queen
e4 bishop g3 it doesn't it doesn't look
great
might be on the doorstep before before
you know it uh alejandra you've got an
english with anton uh bishop on a1 okay
take it away
this is the english between anton
korobov and fabiano caruana you can see
it's in english by the structure
white has not really put any central
pressure you can imagine all of the
rooks came off on the a file no real
need to go through the entire game this
is the current position
close to equal five has just played the
move g5 maybe trying to mix something up
trying to get in some space on the king
side don't expect this one to
be fireworks too many pieces in my
opinion have already been traded so
approximate equality on this one
meanwhile another game that we just
haven't taken a look at richard rapworth
is playing against gabrielescu and this
is a kings
indian attack type of position here on
the king side with the move knight h2 he
might play knight g4 very soon black has
already broken with b5 this is going to
be the opposite there's going to be a
lot of fireworks as white is trying to
break open this king side usually with a
sacrifice on the h6 square and black
saying well i need to do my own counter
play on this side of the board i need to
get b5 c4 or something in in order to
break apart this position with where all
my pieces are so the battle of who gets
there first that's always a fun one i'm
looking forward to this particular game
as opposed to a couple of others thank
you for that and by the way
a few comments
love richie's shirt let's start with the
obvious
second the king's indian tack i love
this comment by r2 yusupuf what attack
yeah and i think this is also sort of
the modern understanding of the opening
is very much that uh and and the plan
that uh david is showing here is
actually very topical where black just
moves away the rook from a fade and then
often you just go h6 you put something
on a fate normally the bishop sometimes
the queen but normally the bishop
and it it solves it solves most of the
uh most of the issues with the potential
sacrifices on the king side and it looks
like you have this mass of pieces of
black king
but there this is sort of the full
extent of what you can achieve very
often and and then black just starts
their own counterplay on queenside
and you
kind of struggle to go any further
because you can play something like
queen g2
and hinted the sacrifice on h6
it doesn't actually win very often when
so many pieces get traded but also you
can play king h7
if black really is scared about it black
can play king h7 and and return the the
ball here there's just one tactical
problem right it's c4 yeah i mean right
right here it loses a full piece yeah
yeah and this is also why bishop and not
queen of f8 was played uh but my my
larger point yes of that the fact like
if you if you play a7 a5 here for
instance just to give you a
demonstration exactly a useful move like
a5 because a5 a4 knight a5 probably is
what we want to do
and white goes knight h6 g8 bishop h6
let's go and we take and we could play
bishop fade sorry queen of fate exactly
it will be very difficult to imagine
exactly where the mating attack is
coming from first of all there
as well but just a pause but just to
show that the peace sacrifice doesn't
win on its own yeah and this is why it's
important to include queen c7 g8 because
quincy's uh the from d8 the queen joins
the the defense much much quicker than
it would have done from the c7 square
exactly
uh but first uh let me interrupt and
jump over to warsaw
with christian what do you have for us
our friend
uh just to build up on uh those last two
games that you guys were having your
eyes on uh between vishwanan and kiril
shivchenko as well as the game between
richie report and david gavriela school
against the youngest players in the
field now i talked with kirill
schaefchenko yesterday over at dinner
and he was saying i played two rash i
was
trying to kill them in the opening and
in the middle game i sacrificed a piece
against richie rapport in the first
round and unfortunately for him these
players these 27 2800s know how to
defend know how to take advantage of
every single mistake so i told him calm
down play a bit of a quieter brand of
chess as well as don't fall behind on
the clock this is a big problem that i'm
seeing from the 19 year olds in the
event both david gavrilasko and kirill
chefchenko they're intimidated it feels
like
about their opposition and they're
spending too much time and this is
exactly what i'm seeing right now as
well check uh the time situation in both
rapport gabrielle school gary let's go
only 15 minutes on the clock richie
report 20 minutes i told them stay
within one minute two minutes um
within that distance of your opponent
you cannot allow yourself to fall five
six minutes behind on the clock and uh
unfortunately for gallery lasko as we
approach uh those uh last five minutes
of the game while uh richie rapport is
going to prepare a sacrifice as we enter
those last five minutes i i'm a bit
worried about this one now let's see
what's happening in the anand chefchenko
i told you yesterday he was i'm going to
be a bit more tame with the black pieces
against vichyanan check what's happening
in the game right now he just sacrificed
two pawns in the last two moves he
played d5 e takes d5 and then e4 and
unfortunately for him vichy said yeah
give me the pawns and right now it's
about uh time to show me the
compensation and there's absolutely no
compensation in the position you're
going to burn your time you're going to
try to find that compensation and you're
not uh going to come up with anything so
this is why i'm worried in these two
games about the youngest participants in
this event guys back to you yeah thank
you christian yeah thank you thank you
thanks for that and i just jump on it i
agree with the general tenor of what
christian was saying but if we can bring
up the uh
on the screen yeah
i want to say that i i agree with the
first part but not the second part
because
he very much sort of listened to you
kind of nodded and and thought to
himself yeah i've spoken to christian
now it's time to do the exact exact
opposite
but
i mean there is compensation here but he
will be down a piece in two moves
basically i think he is actually
planning to go 95 okay i mean now go
ahead tell us what you thought he was
planning i'm pretty sure the idea was to
play 95 long castles knight c3 exactly
exactly i'm pretty sure that was i'm
pretty sure that was what he was
intending and then he realized queen
before queen a2 and probably queen a3
although queen a3 is not forest but
probably queen a3 queen is probably not
enough for for full compensation i still
would have liked to to watch him do this
because
despite only only having one pawn for
the
king on c1 is so precarious
like i just want to play rook c8 a5
before i have long term compensation
here i might want this yeah but then i'm
not worse at all right i know you know
it's even even the end game of the
bishop e7 i think is fine here right i
can play bishop itself sure and just
make you give away this exchanges so
it's two pieces
interesting uh i agree with you when he
ended up he ended up bailing and i don't
like i don't like him bailing because i
think the position he got
that's what i don't like at all that one
i think actually is very very little
compensation right now
now we've castled and now the question
is where is this knight heading so he
played queen b6 here he wants i guess to
play a5 and b4 and the entire play is
very much predicated on
reviving the bishop on f6 lengthening
the diagonal for the bishop one of six
but it seems slow it seems like
against a you know an experienced player
like vichy who understands very much
what is what he is faced with what the
plans are he will find a way to continue
creating counter threats and uh
a5 and before probably never lands yeah
ambition then you don't really have
enough for the two pawns i think you're
almost obliged to play after bishop yeah
bishop d3 is not forced as well yeah but
bishop three is logical now we play
something like queen five or yeah what
have you that was the intention and uh
the 95 knight c3
would have been very funny specifically
after the conversation christian who had
had with him yesterday would have been
extremely funny if he did this in the
first game back
but i also think it would have been
better
yeah
jumped in i mean is that i mean are we
it's whimsical knight takes e3 it's fun
but
is it s
tell me
please the good news
is that it's better than what happened
in the game
it is better than what happens again
right yeah so if you take here e4 takes
knight takes d5 long castle it forces
black to sacrifice the piece of course
we have the spin so knight takes c3
white has no choice you have to take on
c3 right and i assume queen a5 is
definitely a plan and i think i think
black might be doing okay if you get i
don't know one extra tempo even with the
extra tempo i'm not sure like how how
good this is
it's it's compensation but it's not full
compensation even if i just you know
throw a tempo
away away but moves like rook h3 are
really annoying because you don't want
to take with the bishop queen before is
pretty annoying even a move like bishop
d3 asks are you gonna mate
me or am i gonna make you
it's not it's not entirely clear so this
was but this was much better than what
happened in the game because in the game
after bishop d3 as you guys are
mentioning what gets the comp white gets
the
pass depot what gets the attack
yeah you're not very happy that this
king is on c1 because you see a5 and b4
coming you see targets on the side of
the board but it's going to take a while
you still have some time to chill and
explore the development the attack on
the king side the past deep on and by
the moment you start making real threats
black still hasn't gotten his attack
rolling so where's the comp exactly
not really clear to me i think
chefchenko i don't say this very often
but he might have wanted to listen to
christian a little bit
there you have it everybody broadcast
first you might want to listen to
christian okay okay
um
peter jump in on because this game of
richard rapport
uh really does have i like these
maneuvering games where i'm building up
attack building up attack and it's
almost like even though
uh
very little has been traded and in fact
um the undercurrents are like
every tempo can be meaningful now tell
us what's happened and has white
built up at last
an attack
well it's difficult to say and and what
you see richard doing right now is what
you end up defaulting to very often
because it's true yeah because you the
sacrifices on h6 are no longer really on
on the menu uh the the old time of
giving mate the all-time way of giving
mate in the solutions which was to put
the knight on g5 and expect black to
take this really only works with when
black played has played g7 g6 and yeah
with one on h4 of course you don't have
the pawn on h5 yeah but but this idea of
playing h5 and then
building up towards g4 and g5 yeah yeah
we've seen those yeah
fischer has won some games like this
where somehow the knight ends up
nestling in and it's all tactically
brilliant and lightning strikes and
everything else uh yeah but what rishi
is doing is really the the only
realistic way of opening something up on
the king's side and the question is yeah
the question is how much how much black
succeeds in distracting
white on the other side of the board and
right now i think the answer is
richie is way ahead right right in terms
of in terms of
trying achievements
black stem pigo
yeah he kind of
well
what did he do he kind of he put his
bishop queen on c7 back to d8 rook to f8
then he went 97 just because
he wanted to be as discouraging as
possible and
the problem is any c4 or d4 gets met
with the blocking
alternative h5 just taking away a square
and making this next part
possible this movement he has played d5
before now uh i think realizing that he
can no longer really pass and and give
white an absolutely free hand but i'm
not sure what the reply is tonight c4
i'm pretty sure we just go knight c4
here without cd cd
yeah and i'm not sure what the reply is
allowing it to land on this excuse no it
cannot be impossible so we have to take
and now after gta xc4 both knight e7 and
knight d7 are completely hamstrung by
the structure
dc bc looks like we've created a passer
on the a file but what we actually
created is a position in which you will
be very comfortable to be giving mate on
the king side because
this is this is a kind of position that
can drive a coach crazy because we we're
going to tell you don't double your
pawns on anything like this but these
two pawns on c4 and c3 control
absolutely magnificent these knights
would love to hang out on either the d5
and or the d4 squares and the c4 and c3
pawn was playing a fantastic role close
to ideal
yeah structure would much rather have
this and let's say the pawns on c4 and
a4 where black has no passer on the a
file right yeah no this is this is my
other have this dream come true for for
richie and i agree
he's played rook a b8 after takes takes
which is understandable instead of the i
mean gta xc3 beat xc3 is unthinkable
really right so we've played rook a b8
here uh and richie very quickly played
bishop c1
uh which is also
like acute acknowledgment that
everything basically is exactly where it
should be okay two invites queen b3 you
don't want to put anything on b1 because
then black might be able to trade
queen for the queen of the queen for the
rooks so you have to spend a temp on a
somewhat weird looking move but now
white is free to start doing things in
the center and on the case it's sort of
like uh
thor you know winding up with mullinger
you know his magical hammer he's gonna
play g5
and when it lands it's gonna be yeah
it's gonna be cosplay queen e4 bishop
one d3 also probably wins the game if it
happens
e4 bishop f1 bishop d3 looks awesome i
mean it's very slow but also black isn't
really doing very much so it's funny how
like the moment you guys realize one of
the scientists
has a bad position you're just like i
love it i like it i get why
i can play queen e4 i can bring my [ __ ]
it's a pretty good position for white
yes all right yeah we'll leave it there
and we're just going to jump around a
little bit uh because games are heating
up nice night on the rim nintendo in the
rim is dim but if you have two well if
you have two maybe you're doing very
well who knows yeah then that was the
nursery rhyme i learned
what
two nights on the rim by the way this
bishop on a1 i was wondering why white
was a piece down here right i mean no
no he's not and honestly
he might be a bit better exactly it
might be more than a bit better well i
mean the knight is landing on b6 it's
over it's going to hit the ball on e5
yeah exactly
do you have two c7 maybe seven benches
seven
nice right knight b6
also looks right we don't have threats
yet but we have ways to improve our
position i would assume and well this
kind of feels a little awkward like the
desirable knight g6 will only runs runs
into night of five yeah that one you
really really don't want to allow
um
help us out on this one maybe knight d7
is fine though right right here yeah
right let's go 97.
just invite you sort of disentangle
things a little bit
i agree no i don't i don't want to help
you i don't get it
the engine just says queen e6 queen
takes p7 d4 black is slightly better
oh my word you just give up the pawns
you play well there's this there's this
guy on a1 which yasser failed to fail to
even recognize
right
so we want to play we want to maybe hint
at some queen a2 in some futures and
yeah and we also just want to completely
kill it off not not let it move yeah
green d5 is actually very strong
at that point king g one queen a2
actually wins a piece yeah wow some
magical counter play four yeah d4 you
can start with d4 you can start with
queen e6 the whole point put the pawn in
front of the bishop's diagonal so that
it kills the bishop and it allows the
axis of the queen to the king side it's
a bit of a hidden resource but
activity much more important than the b7
pawn here yeah
i think the important point is sort of
never put your queen on c7 because it
has no squares there's no squares then
and having having actually prospects for
that queen is way more important than
preserving the seemingly the base of
your pawn chain you're you know you're
taught to respect the base of the pawn
chain but yes you are yeah uh and the
more the more you're looking at d5 d4
the more you you you realize
whoa that's a massively powerful move
just queen d5 check queen a2
uh is coming uh this knight on e7 which
i kind of thought was
well you know a stick in the mud so to
speak it's not it's not pulling its
weight it suddenly has definitely
another reason another is
uh wow okay we could be witnessing a
turnaround and it's kind of magical
because i'm sure when anton's doing all
of this queen a8 knight a4 you know he's
you know the the
the dopamine
is going this is great this is great i'm
feeling good i'm feeling good
what's happening in the hedgehog
uh alejandro
hippo hippo different animal come on
yeah i got that wrong
it's a curious decision that radhik
voitasha has taken here we see this
position basically the same thing you
got the strong center black has actually
put the pawn on c4 started some kind of
spanish type activity in the queen side
and here you could close things down
with a5 you could also keep the tension
as white played a move h4 or he could
commit push the pawn to e5 and force a
reaction from black the question i have
is what is he planning to do against
bishop takes f3 you don't really want to
take with the queen because of this
problem takes it on e5 and i don't think
you want to take with a rook if you
think with the rook you just play b4
knight ft5 something like this i'm not
really sure why you would have given me
the d5 square but if you take it's the
same thing knight fd5 and b4 is coming
and this knight is it's huge it's a
great knight now why did i take on f3
first because if i take it this way and
you take with the knight maybe h4h5
comes and maybe here with a knight here
you do actually get play on against the
king's side but if you eliminate the
knight first
i think this looks terrible for white
you get knight ft5 the spawn on e5 is
immediately hanging with an important
part of taking on f3 first and the move
b4 is coming the move bishop takes e5 is
coming you have to defend against all of
these things 97 taking on e5 is also
going to be an available plan
and you definitely don't want to take
with a pawn i'm assuming you're taking
with the queen so this i think is a very
strong sequence right now for duda
taking advantage of the fact that
perhaps e5 was mistimed definitely not
approved by the engines hate the move
think after bishop takes f3 black is
already much better because i assume
they're gonna take with the bishop the
engines think that it's only a little
bit better for black but that's because
they assume that you take with the g
pawn i don't know about that
you don't normally play e5 to recapture
this it actually makes some sense here
but i really really hate uh whoa
45 yeah he hasn't taken off i am shocked
by that i actually i just wanted to ask
you peter uh you know me i'm the pawn
grabber here uh bishop f3 queen of three
he didn't mention that alejandro but
take stakes with the people i'm not sure
why not 97.
my eyes kind of like
kind of flashed amber alert signal uh
look at that that that looks like a
pretty clean pawn to me yeah but you
know honestly i think gf is just much
stronger
we go gf and therefore we support the
pawn on e5 then we try to put the knight
on e4 aim towards the d6 i'm pretty sure
that was the plan but i still really
really dislike uh just like e5 just
because
i've played this position
this structure
i don't have much experience playing
against the hippo specifically but you
get exactly the structure let's say if
we go back back to move 16
uh prior to e4 e5 yeah uh
these types of structures whether black
plays c5 c4 or cd4 cd4 which i think
happened more in my games you get them
from bishop b5 check 97 lines quite a
bit yes and
reviving that bishop on b7
is sort of never on your agenda like
it's supposed to be very restricted by
the pawn on e4 and you're supposed to
continually asking uh to be continued
asking the question or of black do you
want to play g5 e594 do you want to play
e5 g5 and leave it on b7 forever and
doomed
or are you just going to let me play
freely here uh without really
challenging my center in any way
i really don't don't quite understand
why we've given that bishop squares
and why we have opened up the the long
diagonal for it
h4 here rook having played rook a2 why
aren't we playing rook ea one for
instance i don't quite understand right
uh
yeah i'm i'm surprised by raleigh's
decision i i i don't know why he felt
obliged to play play five here at all
could could the e pawn be somehow weak i
could like take twice on a4 and queen c6
i don't know yeah okay
rook a1 maybe not not the way to go even
though
i mean it it it it sort of starts to get
made yeah this is a bit this is a bit
annoying actually that's a very good
point yeah yeah i don't know it's uh you
you would you certainly like to think
that hey you know white does have some
something honestly somewhat somewhat
weirdly i'm not against the idea of
playing even a 4a5 maybe and then just
switching everything to the king side
which is what i wanted to ask you peter
uh
i studied the games of boris baskey and
uh one of the things that i noticed that
whenever spassky played the breyer he
was really anxious to sacrifice a knight
for two pawns on the d5 square and he
won some wonderful games on the black
side of the sacrifice did you were you
raised with this kind of classical yeah
i did this
yeah i i like i like that as well uh as
a kid because yeah it it it gives you a
position some somewhere to breathe it's
not it's normally like quote unquote
unsound right but it's much more fun
than retreating to d7 and playing this
cramped position where none of your
stuff goes anywhere
also so
yeah i'm very much of the same opinion
it's just that i think in 2022 you don't
expect this to be machine approved no of
course because yeah
we've learned that those compensations
aren't entirely enough now conversely
capturing on e5 knight takes e5
oops sorry i think the bishop bishop d5
was played a5 knight bg7 and before
knight f7 is always something that you
want to
be concerned about hence we saw the move
bishop d5 uh you know revitalizing uh
strengthening if you will the uh
the the pawn on e6 the seven of three
if white had a pawn on b4 you would be
very very happy but black i think will
start pushing b5 before uh very uh very
soon maybe even immediately i don't
really see why you wouldn't do it
immediately and well i have to sidestep
b3 yeah we probably yeah we pretty much
never take on before breaking up our own
structure and
yeah i still feel like this is a pretty
decent outcome for white i think maybe
you do too yeah and this is where bishop
takes f3 comes in i understand that you
know after the impassioned speech i i i
gave about you know giving this bishop
square i was moved man i mean the tears
almost started rolling down my cheeks
it's uh it's a bit disingenuous to
suggest you know you absolutely give it
up it's an obvious movement it's not
really that obvious but right i think it
was clearly stronger than what we've
gotten here exactly i think white's for
choice uh alejandro what's oh sorry
we'll just wait for a moment as you
yes indeed
[Laughter]
and it looks like in in the meantime we
had a lot of moves happen in the rapport
governors game we also have what but but
i gotta toss it over to alejandro for
the wesley
sow game what's happening there i mean
wow
certainly the landscape changed in this
one even though perhaps the evaluation
hasn't because here the move knight d4
was played and you could play a bunch of
things f5 his possible knight a5 hitting
the rook was one of them but does this
does invite wesley to change the
character of the position you could just
retreat the rook but wesley said well
let's see what happens if i sacrifice an
exchange you do get two pawns for it and
it's one of those positions where it's
not easy immediately to see
what's stronger here the bishop and the
two pawns or the rook a rooker is very
active and if it finds itself attacking
weaknesses like h4 and a4 it's going to
be difficult for white to defend them
that being said it's two extra pawns and
the bishop is on an open diagonal and an
open board and the knight is not great
so who's better in this position or for
me it's hard to say i
like the rook
but material is very reduced rookie sam
was played checking e7 knight e6 is
currently in the battle that we have i'm
gonna see rook c3 rook a3 come on the
board there will be positions where you
could go knight d4 knight at five you
pick up h6 in many positions so this is
gonna be a very sharp end game i have a
feeling that it should be a draw with
proper play but i think that at some
point it's gonna heat up with both sides
having their chances
yeah i i like the two pawns because i
like the fact that the knight is on a5
but it's one of those things that it's a
la tempo right i mean just as alejandra
was saying you get your rook
and knight
coordinating um it's going to be great
boy talk about uh
having a measure of one another yeah
that's so that's a long long record for
for rabbit emblems considering how how
few
tournaments there are on the calendar of
rapid and blitz compared to yeah that's
actually kind of surprising yeah does
this does this count their uh high break
uh from america
oh from bucharest
probably probably we don't know for sure
but we assume it probably does yeah yeah
well somebody's uh keeping great stats
if that were the case i just wanted to
turn our attention to the game of anton
and fabi uh not too surprising for me
but fabi didn't pick up on the strength
of d5 d4 just killing this bishop right
he's going for a similar sort of
spiritually parts of it are very similar
once again he's not even remotely
interested in protecting the pawn on b7
he wants to activate the queen right but
compared to what we were discussing the
bishoprian is very much alive here which
leads me to think that black is probably
fine you get the feeling that after the
move queen e2 that he played he will
find a way to trade off the knight on h4
and give some kind of a perpetual but
white also should be entirely in trouble
here i don't really expect white to have
any problems uh
equalizing
um seems to me like a position where uh
some kind of perpetual is extremely like
knight g6 or if you take on f6 bishop
takes f6 and then take one h4 and start
giving checks uh
should be a draw uh because you always
have this well not a five even yeah
because we have this perpetual
construction the moment the black queen
gets access to the ff3 square
uh white will have to
accept uh the draw yeah
feels
feels right okay still a lot of games
going on uh
things are heating up
richie's game look at this
yeah richard's game very i'm very
curious
yeah
my first my first instinct was to say it
must be absolutely winning for white but
i
have been unable to
first thing was that black white had
incredible compensation and they
realized their equal material
incredible conversation i know i know
exactly what you mean yeah
it looks it looks absolutely winning
in part because of exactly that same
reason that like you you normally have
to sacrifice something for a position
like this but black actually isn't far
away from some kind of stability like
you play knight f5 here i would assume
c3 is hanging we do finally have some
counter play yeah but it looks like
queen takes e3 here i mean maybe we're
not that bad oh it was it was totally
it's like plus seven
what about now now it's only plus three
okay only only well let's take you
through
some lines because rookie four queen
takes e3's on the board and we're gonna
have a few moves quickly we can keep up
with the players check has been played
you have to play king f8 if you play
knight g6 i will happily
happily take
that on g6 so don't even think about
that one king f8 has to be played i'm
surprised it hasn't been played already
damn we're gonna drop in but that's the
thing right you drop in with the queen
the bishop is more or less trapped uh
king e8 is one move but it's not very
human bishop takes e5 is kind of crazy
but it might be your best chance because
at least you're hitting the rook at the
end of course you couldn't take on the
previous move queen takes h8 but you can
take on a5 there's rook b1 is not a move
because the queen is guarding this
square there's no real problems with the
move queen e1
picking up stuff because remember queen
h is such a big problem right here and
here it is queen h7 and because queen
head is such a big problem in every
position you don't have the time to
untether your queen to the diagonal
which means that white's just basically
winning in this revolution it should be
a full if
full on a killing attack peter right
that that feels
yeah that feels gone uh yeah i'm a bit
surprised i didn't think he absolutely
needed not to react to gtx h6 if we go
back to like move 20 a 29-ish tell me
when to stop
yeah even knight b6 is maybe not first
but let's see here knight b6 gh yeah i
thought
you have to kind of close your eyes and
go she takes h6 here
or perhaps knight f5 from the previous
move and then ghgh
and i was inspired by what you suggested
earlier if you could put your bishop but
now we have an f5 square for for the
night which will blunt some of that
plan right i mean
i think the issue is more than we don't
really if we don't take on c4 here we
don't really have counterplay as such
right we we're kind of stuck shuffling
things around but yeah what he got in
the game you do feel like you're going
to get mated i do i do you do get the
feeling that you're going to get back oh
sorry i think that was my my bad let me
uh
where
where am i
sorry
wrong game and we do have the queen yeah
he's gone king e8 which is a move that
yeah alejandra mentioned it's possible
to make this move but it doesn't really
change the aviation very much the idea
of course being that if white does take
on h8 with check we play king d7 and now
both the rook on a1 is still hanging in
the king and the queen on h8 is also
hanging
but richie very commonly goes rook ga4
defense defends the rook and also
regrettably for black if you play bishop
takes e5 i think bishop did your d2 is
always going to be very very hurtful
yeah that is that's you can take only
one twice but then after knight g5 your
entire king side collapses and the the
the h pawn is still alive
you never say that like specifically
knight g5 if you give black one more
tempo to somehow not lose the f7 pawn
with check
maybe you can uh have some hopes for the
future but that's exactly the problem
peter you lose the f7 pawn with check
the e6 pumpkins would check and suddenly
you're flushed away yeah
everything collapses yeah and as
predicted this game did end in a draw
one of the many perpetuals that we were
thinking about
so let's just see how it happened yep
you called it peter that was the whole
yeah and i'd say at 96 all nighter five
i assume would have led to the same yeah
yeah once the knight on h4 is traded
away or lowered away you you get the
f3d1 f3 g1 perpetual
and uh yeah once again yeah they
they've done the thing without doing the
thing without doing the thing but yeah i
really hope the arbiters don't give them
a hard time for it the perpetual check
was inevitable
best played by both sides and a draw and
over to you alejandro is vishy doing his
perfect thing this is a funny game
because the way that kiril chefchenko
plays chess it's like material does not
exist in this man but also time
management doesn't exist it's not a good
combination
because we had in this position yeah
three seconds i think or nine seconds
like he made he made a move on three
seconds we'll let rishi think on this
one but if you go to this position he
just kept sacrificing stuff the move b4
just throws the kitchen sink you can
play knight c4 and take this rook you
can even consider taking him before you
can even invade and go to move c4 knight
c4 was the one chosen queen b7 was
played in the game you're curious why we
didn't take on e5 i couldn't really
figure out why we don't take honestly
there's not enough time to explain like
everything but knight takes c5 was the
engine recommendation and there were
lines afterwards like knight takes
bishop takes beat ac3 the line goes on
but the engine doesn't really believe in
this attack instead she takes before it
was playable and you might be wondering
why not queen takes pins the knight
saves the rook for now regains a pawn
but as i said chevchenko paul is not
about that queen thanks before quindi
trades the queens which might be the
reason that shivchenko didn't want to go
into that everything is losing so he
says well if i'm losing let me just keep
the queens on and try to attack rook b5
vichy says i gotta defend this guy a3 a5
play rook h3 shivchenko now we can
switch down to his last 10 seconds yeah
we should probably be watching it like
this right and then take some b4 a4
beautiful beautiful move to close the
shop and he's consolidating right you
can just see that the rook on h3 does a
beautiful job of defending b3 if
necessary the the one the one issue i
see here for white well slight issue is
that uh you probably play something like
king b1 here and then the pawn on a4
will get attacked by either queen a7 or
queen a6 or something and the only real
way to protect it would be to play b2b3
which does actually open up the bishop
on f6 black
you know the bishop itself doesn't
really win you the game you need to get
the queen closer to those squares to
actually do something and the queen from
either a7 or a6 doesn't really have a
good path towards the dark squared
long diagonal but
you would prefer not to have to play b3
and yeah this is also actually kind of
smart he goes can be on b3
creating a very strong idea of queen
before right if you give black a tempo
here i have a feeling if you well if you
allow queen before here you might
actually be in trouble with white but
obviously it's white to move
meaning that uh you could just move like
98 knight day three or something but 93
is not a very pleasant move to make
because
like rook c2 here are you sure you want
to do this ooh rook c2 yeah rook c2
excuse me
full stop see another three i think is
wrong but maybe queen e3 is good you
know queenie three queen takes b3 and
this is pretty nice queen a7 he's done
it queen with queen a7
are you actually turning queen takes a4
queen take c5 well it becomes tricky but
i'm guessing the king runs away yeah
bishop takes b2 first knight takes
between a1 check but by the way there is
still a d-pawn in this one so if i go
like queen takes b3 and you go like b8
unfortunately these prefer
i would prefer not to honestly i would
like if they're you know what i'm saying
though you know
yes but
like if there's any choice at all i
would prefer not to touch the pawn on b3
here because that does give black a lot
of activity man the top engine move is
so brutal and it's so good and it's so
straightforward d7 it's rook f3
but then it goes queen a4 knight a3 i
think on your screen right does it what
happens if i just take out f6
oh no it doesn't go no no no sorry yeah
i'm sorry yeah so the computer engine
stop move is rook f3 basically saying
rook takes effect yeah like if if that
piece is gone from the board the wind
becomes the wind becomes very very uh
straightforward in most cases so yeah
it's uh could i ask the question why d7
again i know what i like to say i'm just
i'm mesmerized by the impact but i think
i think we ignore it i think we go like
g6 well yeah as i have to say don't
ignore it too much because i'm going to
go 28 g6 or h5 or i don't know gg6 i
think because i don't think you have are
this threatening mate the threat was
made yeah this is why i didn't want to
play g6 let's go instead of g6 let's go
um
yes yes but i hate everything else as
well
yeah i hate everything else as well i
just say if you play h5 i'm ready for
you chicken bishop to three chips
uh uh please sign the scoresheet right
we're having fun
are we having fun after d7 uh alejandro
no because there's an engine move i
don't want to put on so we're not having
fun with that game oh he's a party poopy
nobody's ever going to find that
well out of necessity you might you
might because everything else just loses
very very straightforwardly to
background threats and there's also
points i really want to take this pawn
and your bishop's not on f6 hitting b2
and
i don't know
a moment ago i tried knight a3 and you
went rook c2 and hurt my feelings were
your bishop not on f7 but now c5 is
protected so i'm just kidding
we'll take on the seven hours yeah and
the game sort of continues i assume g7
doesn't throw everything away but game
very much continues after bishop seven
yeah and rook f3 though that's the crew
f3 is a cruncher but it's a tough move
to find
these seven players i think it's
he kind of needs to play bishop seven
because we we went through the list and
we kind of i think we explained why all
the noises g6 h5 those lures so it's
either bishop seven or king of faith but
nobody goes king of say king of eight
here so the question is you need to
realize you know you can actually move
the bishop away from its ideal uh
diagonal it's not an easy move to make
like exactly your entire counterplay is
based on the bishop on f6 exactly and
now you have to uh
you know close your eyes and move it
away yeah yeah
i mean that's a human move right
how do you play
how do you play bishop yeah but now h5
just is crunchy because you you
reintroduce the mating threat of queen
e8 and h6 made i don't know and black is
just going to fall behind
do you want to include queen e8 no i
think i go h5 here so g6 h5 immediately
yeah i think i'm just afraid well afraid
but bishop e7
but now hghd quincy three is kind of
mate on in in that direction
this is the issue yeah because like
we've actually opened up we we have
actually opened up the h file for white
to give counter made there you know yeah
okay uh that is kind of funny actually
sorry i just have to put that on the
board this idea including yeah yeah yeah
and you you take over the long diagonal
that's not a threat that you usually see
against the fianchetto bishop yeah like
it's uh okay and this is why
h5 on the board yeah knight e5 on the
board as well
now you just take the knight knight
takes knight and a4 we have queen takes
b3 for all else fails with a very very
easily very difficult position yeah you
can also probably throw in h takes g6 i
don't think it
spoils anything
uh
http is not a threat knight c4 with the
pin on the rook on c5 is not a threat
either i mean queen a4 would be a threat
but we take so much on the king's side
that it doesn't really make
holy smokes guys i mean
no seriously
for her i think before seems very very
vishy will sit there and say you know
what took me so long to get back into
competitive uh chess i mean this is uh
yeah this is uh sweet
yeah it is it is very heartwarming
and just to switch to some of the other
games i wanted to wesley so
switch to the richard game because it's
just about
over here you get the feeling there is
mate on the yeah i mean
something has to be made here
nothing like a good king hunt uh there
is rook takes just east
he's just gone bishop takes d5 attacking
the knight on uh yeah that's easy enough
right that's that just ends the game
straight away yeah king or king takes
king takes war i mean he had no choice
it's like we're not criticizing this
move he had he had no choice
and now queen of three check i mean i
would have just played queen of three
check here and i think that's the
the simplest you just start chasing yeah
the king cannot the their
land mines on d6 and d4 squares that
will walk into a i think i think it
actually kind of does end the game yeah
queen f3 is just the only king six
bishop follows as the full queen going
forward to the fourth rank will get you
mated and your
foreign also costs you the full queen so
yeah it's just they're just made
actually
i'm guessing i'm guessing most moves
here which aren't the blunder of queen
and one are
in the range of plus five two plus
twelve but queen f3 seems to be the
cleanest yeah
is probably completely winning for white
but there's also a pollinator like that
i don't like that open h file who
invited that opening i like g8 square
being covered by the pawn on h7 as well
well it's gonna wow
if it was the winds right you can't
criticize that clear yeah clear clear uh
but queen f3 was very very complicated
it was very pretty right yeah yeah it
was right now it takes and now we got
queen of three i guess
whoa richie's
seven richards
they're all good king d6 bishop f
[Laughter]
goes forward yeah yes and i think i
think we can also find something wrong
with him
that now this is the type of position
where everybody in the vultures
vultures are like they're everywhere
okay four okay four king d3 queen of
three and it will be made like the king
will get to the you know the to the
actual opposing back rank and right
somebody
somebody said something about staircase
mate or whatever yeah like queen of
three kingdom k2 and then i have to only
there's only one check after king c1 but
it will be enough it'll be good enough
right queen a3 is it the only way to
make it is right
well i mean i have a feeling if we pass
we still win like if i play king of one
in that position i'll probably still win
but but why do it
that's true actually
i mean probably still winning not to
criticize his approach but he
he can trick himself yeah i mean
i'm surprised he chose this i think i
think there was absolutely no no reason
not to just win the game instantaneously
with checks when
both rooks were on the board exactly it
makes it easier to give mate
yeah i'm very surprised queen of queen
of three churches and by the way we do
have a handshake in the veswanathon
anand as gary
four out goes four
yeah the streak this is
look at this
we were we were privileged here in st
louis when um fabiano went on a 7-0
streak in classical chess which was
really remarkable what four out of four
and this one this one's almost over the
youngsters having trouble
in warsaw
19 year old schaeffchenko and 19 year
old gabrielesco have only been able to
score one draw out of eight games ouch
ouch
and quincy force still wins i'm i'm yeah
i'm in a very weird position of trying
to criticize somebody who is currently
probably like mate and eight
check check i mean
do you got queen g7 king h2 so that is
when you go bishop h okay we're looking
for the artistic finish yes bishop
anywhere bishop bishop c3 check i don't
want to be artistic no no bishop before
or whatever yeah bishop which play five
maybe just play five don't you feel you
also should resign that
well bishop bishop h6 yeah is this
bishop a5 force queen d2 is that yeah
like is the only legal move in the
position right so yeah i don't know why
we're continuing here but all right ah
richie richie all right very good let's
go to the levon game because that one
definitely heat it up as you can see
that levon has misplayed this end game
his king is on g7 and it just did not
belong there the king is too passive on
g7
but he was sort of prompted to do that
because he allowed h4 h5 and now the
pawn h6 is a legitimate target it's a
legitimate target look what's happened
to the board he has this problem that
the knight has landed on c6 he's
beautiful square yeah he's not on time
to take on a4 so rook a3 knight takes a5
rook a4 knight c4 just doesn't work
correct so you have to decide what to do
with the knight if you take on c6
unfortunately that's a seriously
powerful passer
yeah i'm still tempted to try to do this
like breaking a fade here king f8 no we
need we need the king closer to the c6
pawn here okay can i go but it looks
horrible yeah king of five king is seven
e4 and then the king goes in
and the king goes in yeah this looks
horrible
i couldn't agree with you more one of
these passers either the h by the way
the bishop on d5 is just a monster even
if
long
you take my a pawn and then you push
your pawn all the way to a3 the bishop
on t5 says i've been waiting waiting
what took you so long yeah perhaps this
is the best defense still to take on b7
but of course white is now better
you have this powerful pawn on b5 that's
past ice yeah you would like to play
knight c5 knight a4 here but that allows
bf no b6 actually maybe is a draw right
so maybe you do that you take take and
if white plays b6 here i think by this
point he's gone i'm surprised he's
played this so quickly maybe there's
nothing stronger but you get the feeling
that this knight ending is
far and away black's best but actually
the lightning is so restricted yeah but
it's actually a really bad end game
right yeah
by the way knight takes b6 i completely
agree is black's best yeah
a chance
and wouldn't it be amazing
dare we say if left got away left got
away with this again uh following what
you you had asked me to do uh alejandro
if you see this anyway how bad is it the
end just think it's fine like plus one
and black should hold somehow but this
knight is kinda yeah like if you allow a
four or five here the knight is actually
gone right it will never return it will
never move yeah so it will die actually
it will die
i think 97 is a mistake i think you're
supposed to play knight c7 and like aim
it towards the g7 square via e8 maybe
this is the plan
f7 king of seven and then knight e8
that's a pretty good plan yeah it's a
great plan actually yeah i think yeah
and uh yeah i thought 97 was first and i
thought was borderline losing but yeah
97 like we go king
is king f7 here right
we force a king to g4 it seems like like
i will play knight e8 on ip66 yeah i
will go knight g7 check there
97 e4 maybe we can even play a 5 check
question mark yeah excellent oh he
didn't do it he allowed the pawn to go
oh that's crazy
crazy you must have thought the knight
engine was lost panicked and made some
other move but with the pawn on b7
there's no way right wait a minute
possibly work yeah no way
so instead of taking this very very
surprising to me he made a check
so
why doesn't just everything yeah i think
he he calculated this somehow there's
always there's only two legal moves
right yeah
is correct because king e4 knight c5 i
take on b7 that's clear now if we go
king b4 then he can go knight c5 and
four i'm pretty sure this is yeah this
is the plan but it's but why
oh because b8 i have um
yeah we can under promote to a knight
but yeah and i didn't
stop it
uh king b5
why not king bf liking v5 flux looks
strong
i wonder if you still play knight like
like knight c3 what do you let's three
kings c5 for king c6 yeah one of those
just
i i any
i think a slightly weaker move yeah now
knight c5 actually gives black up
no
i mean if levon saves this no
it's just no way no no way by the way
before was a mistake
right yeah yeah i mean why was that a
knight a6 check much better king b5 just
was yeah okay give me five king d4 yeah
we can go b8 knight here i i thought
about it the other promotion but that's
not why we put a pawn on b7
okay knight b5 guys is that c5 also
objectively not good because of knight
d3 right
pardon me no no i wasn't suggesting it
seriously yeah three is very strong no
i'm i'm thinking knight b5 yeah and
there my question is we have knight
we have knight a6
he put his knight back on but i was also
wondering how bad it would be to play
knight b7 bishop b7 rookie one yes so
that was going on 994 94 is actually my
shot default 94 is even stronger
that's easy and that's easy and we're
covering h1 with our bishop as well but
now that this piece is so
uh passive on d7 yeah wesley has played
94 here which is once again yeah this is
where you want this knight to be oh it's
a dream yeah it's a dreamboat night park
it park it on five and then think from
there where with your entire structure
completely safe
still a very difficult position
loose pieces drop off defend your pieces
in these endings if you can put your
pawn on e4 which defends your bishop on
e4 your knight on f5
do it yeah
and actually we also see the earlier
nicely nicely played end game uh sort of
bearing fruit for wesley because the
bondage six is
in in dire dire trouble now exactly
again this bishop is a monster in the
defense if white picks up the h6 pawn
here without giving up anything yeah the
the two very very outside passers
probably decide the game in white's
favor i would assume i would have said
there will be one check though is a bit
awkward
uh now because if you if you play king
c4 knight b6 knight g5 is an obvious
response and if you play king c3
maybe black has time enough to play
knight c5 and exactly and try to pick up
the pawn on b7 and if the paul b7
actually does fall
your situation
he's gone bishop b3 and levon
immediately replies with rook h1 knowing
that that h-pawn is actually such a
dangerous yeah you need to get rid of
the h5 pawn if if at all possible
basically or your situation very much
depends on it
okay
i mean again i mean
credit he's not crazy he's putting a
challenge
to his opponent in a very very difficult
circumstance and in the meantime we we
should still be watching this but i will
say that uh young sister is trying to to
outplay radic from
that slight slightly quiet position but
oh yeah the material is
maybe low enough for for addict to hold
but it's unclear by the way king b5 yeah
this is a very concrete way to perhaps
win sort of by force like rook h5
we probably played bishop b6 first i
don't know king c6 is also possible but
bishop e center so we play this b6 we
force knight b8 and then we try to chase
it with the king but as usual the key
it's so easy the king on its own doesn't
actually win that duel against no the
knight kind of flip-flops all over the
table
um wait what is the light we're thinking
rook h5 he's done it rocket h5 you can't
actually go king c6 yeah you have to
play he's played e4 which is maybe a
smarter move than b6 because he wants to
train up the bishop right he wants to
put his bishop on c4 rook h3 played to
trap i live on
to trap the knight when you go king
b7
king c c7 sorry um
so where do we where do we put our
bishop here as well probably still d5
because it's so
you know it's difficult to blunder it
there it's protected
yeah but yeah wesley goes with bishop c4
i was wondering about that but now you
have to have a move after brooks i guess
rook c3 he wants to go e5 e67 maybe this
is what he's pushing for wow actually
creating creating a second passer we've
got another very prominent passer and
immediately rook
c
three yeah uh intending to meet e5 with
takes on c4 or i think that might be
lost i think the issue for black is
going to be yeah the h pawn is too far
away uh to distract the knight on the
five quickly enough i think you lose
that position
if if if they weren't as low on time we
could try showing it on the analysis
board like e5 we double take we take on
c4 right we're expecting yeah but wesley
correctly i think decides against it but
now the king is coming in like if the
king lands on c7 i i don't want the king
to land yeah if one is getting closer
and closer to this is amazing
this is this is the moment this is where
wesley has to be alert knight g8 knight
f6 is winning knight g8 yeah knight f6
knives 40 seconds and moves like nigeria
checkup he was very alert against nepo
when he played that move bishop f7 he's
looking no
wrong way
oh
he was so close wait what he could have
played
keep missing these things against levon
well i mean i'm telling you it's uh i
mean
united states is not hard not hard not
at all yeah
it's so yeah you would assume you know a
player of wesley's caliper finds it but
but now i think leon just saves this yep
it's just it's just blockaded he gets a
king to c7 and then he chose
so
just a second is it so simple i go
knight d4 i don't even see a plan
oh oh he played bishop there should be
five games
or whatever yeah
oh my gosh king c7 i'm assuming knight
d4
yeah yeah i didn't think it was so well
what's the threat like how do you use
the five 96 yeah i mean i can go 97 here
if i want right roxy one is also fine
just to move it away from forks right
yes
very professional move there by levon
because you like the way you lose this
is you blunder some kind of a stupid
force no no no question about
with 96 94. wow lavon just i know
everything
and there's so many
different
ways of that i've lost
of having a lost position
tactically strategically yeah
says no to a repetition i don't think
he's playing for a win necessarily but
he says yeah
that belongs on d7 i don't need to
grovel
i'm going to make this job comfortably
yeah that badly yeah yeah it's also a
good technique on a three-fold
repetition you could make a move that
makes a position worse hold on there was
bishop e6 there what would you have done
on bishop bc couldn't be one check
always exists right a rook be watching
and it's just i wanted to you know drive
the knight back to b8 and perhaps put
the bishop on c8 i don't know he didn't
do it he played knight b3 yeah number
three would go rook for one i assume
sort of provoke a five so we'd never
even have to think about that again
right that's and then we play i don't
know rugby one and we chill exactly we
really do chill by this point like it's
just
not even close anymore there's there's
not a semblance of
okay i i mean you know the vaughn dies
from first wonderful wonderful wonderful
but i mean that there ought to be
something like how many lost positions
will uh levon achieve and go undefeated
yeah like at some point like you collect
enough of enough stamps right on the
ground
yeah there's going to be a handshake in
the youngsters of game
momentarily or because whoa whoa whoa
whoa guys what's what happened here
uh black is winning yeah that's what we
were saying
oh my goodness and that's just it
yeah i'll play them slowly from a
position which
didn't look that horrible but
by the way there for uh duda that's such
an important victory yeah in front of
the polish fans with the black pieces
two points for the rapid it was a huge
he came in with a fighting spirit with a
hippo yep and he got what he wanted
he sure did and he outplayed uh his
opponent in a lengthy game
nice and back to
uh this is our final game of the round
yeah and uh looks like now we will
finally get this repetition that we were
kind of threatening
uh threatening our viewers with yeah
threatening our viewers with the
repetition
take that you you viewers
oh my goodness uh yep what a game how
many how many wins did vichy me avishi
did wesley this
plenty plenty plenty i mean you go down
this game and you will see that the
engine had wesley on plus five
throughout most of it most of the end
game clearly the most
uh relevant point where you think this
is where i can finish the game off
was right here right instead of going
knight f5 check in this position we
mentioned the move knight g8 check the
king kent because of the bishop action
on e6 and f7 you can't keep
touch with the pawn on f6 has to go
somewhere and you have just about enough
time to take on f6 here because that
pawn is not defended the knight cannot
defend b8 and f6 at the same time it's
overloaded and here you just have these
two pass pawns defend different than the
game and it's over white just wins there
were other cases uh previously like once
the pawn got to b7 there was the plan of
putting the bishop on c6 especially oh
sorry on c6 and then b5 just to trap the
knight on b8 and then attack it and it
does it doesn't really matter that you
come and take my pawn and start pushing
it's too slow so in many cases here in
this positions
and when he started giving checks
obviously here king b5 is like another
easy one much much easier than king b4
because it allows this knight c5 the
movement right king yes allows the
knight back into the game but even this
is winning and at this point he went for
the h6 pawn but bishop c6 knight b8 and
then just king b5 we'll start with
bishop b5 king b5 is fine the idea is to
go king b6 bishop b5 if you attack the
knight on a7 you just die i mean you
can't defend the knight and the knight
is trapped and the moment that you move
the night out i take it and promote so
you don't have time you can't even play
rook h1 it's just dead dead so more than
one maybe more than 10 ways for wesley
to win but levon keeps drawing these
games remarkably remarkable but a man
that won his round richard report is in
warsaw with christian
thank you alejandro we are indeed with
the dominant victor of the round richie
rapport richie welcome to the studio
tell us your first impressions of poland
and the rapidem blitz
uh yeah i have been to poland already
and i have been playing rapid employees
in poland so you know
uh not much uh has changed in this
regard oh it's a new event and it's
going uh well i mean from an
organization point of view from my play
point of view it's going okay i guess 50
in the first uh day how would you assess
that
i guess i had two blacks i would say
it's okay but of course
i had probably more in my games but it's
no more result yeah last game i lost
kind of stupidly um so obviously that
was not so satisfying but um other than
that okay this is wreckage so if
anything goes in today you chose this uh
e4 followed by uh d3 kings indian attack
sort of set up how did you approach
today's game did you wanted to go out
and play a long game make him think how
did you approach it yeah i usually play
like this in in
european blitz i was spoiled for my
extra valencia so it's not
obviously in the most principled move
but okay i
i guess i like or maybe not i don't like
because white is i think almost
always even worse in these positions but
i feel like with shorter time controls
uh maybe it can get um
slightly difficult to play as black and
i think this is what happened in the
game and there was this maneuvering
phase
what would you say the critical moments
well i mean i was like when he played b5
okay yeah this is completely normal
normal stuff standard stuff and then
yeah so it was
yeah this bit is a mistake obviously
because um
structure i think he forgot that i can
play c3 because it would be a little
slightly different story i was forced to
capture but after c3
96 abm just clearly better has no
squares and so the idea being that if
you take take now c3 yeah this is not
yeah i mean it still is completely fine
of course but not as bad as the game was
for him yeah and after the next one was
yeah i tried to then go for this idea
with g4 which i did in the game and
probably next moment was when he played
the d4
i think after d4 um
yeah like i think here like
like i am just clearly better in
afghanistan4 and dc it's a bit uh
absurd because he hasn't passed pawn and
i have double pawns but uh i have bishop
pair and
my uh
strange structure is you know kind of
dominating his knight so he has no
squares and then i you know ended up
getting a mid-attack after that uh he
went uh for a walk his king went for uh
a walk oh nice somewhere around here and
he went king to e8 and it felt like
maybe he's hiding but how did you assess
the position at this point are you sure
that you were winning pretty much yeah i
mean i am maybe down upon for a while
but okay i'm taking it on a5 so
basically it's equal material i have
bishop where i have a pawn on it's
heaven almost which i'm promoting and
his king is totally exposed and i have
no virtually weaknesses yet so i mean i
wasn't too skeptical it's just very
awkward position so
maybe it could be a little bit confusing
but i was not
adopting too much that you know i should
be the one who is um
calling the shot sort of richie you're
playing uh fabiano caruana with the
black pieces in just uh 10 minutes
preface that game for us
yeah
no idea i like to play fabian so we'll
see um
it'll be fun that's for sure definitely
having our eyes on that thank you very
much richie and good luck in the next
game and we will be going on a break
stay tuned we'll be coming back shortly
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of bank
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to day two of the
warsaw super bad rapid and blitz and the
sendings are uh have fun
yeah wow pretty clear and uh leaders uh
the two leaders up top there uh this
year a hundred percent by the way yeah
yes and uh the the local favorite
youngster dude the man who will play the
cannabis tournament in a month time in
in madrid in clear second on home crowd
is happy deliriously happy with do this
result absolutely doing doing really
well won a nice game on the black side
against another of the local players uh
raleigh voyager who is not having such a
great event
fabian livon on five out of eight uh as
is richard grapport who won
a very nice attacking game last round
and uh for today's promotion for peter
yes yes this is this is the the item of
the day uh uh magnetics yeah it's a it's
a magnetic eight-inch wooden travel set
uh crafted from maple and ebony features
fully magnetic pieces and comes with a
great traveling case to hold
all of your pieces and available as is
with most cases uh with most things we
promote on the show at cubaticstl.com
uh
uh it it's a very very nicely looking uh
nicely looking set and uh
this is one of my favorite travel sets
uh uh one that i carried around for that
part of 40 years the pieces are the same
it's a different um
these are magnetic i used to have the
pegged
sets yeah like they they slotted it i i
grew up on on both of those things i
didn't uh
uh
i don't think i traveled very much with
magnetic sets but uh i we definitely had
them in
in-house so this way but the peg sets
yeah yeah and as the games get underway
we are again in round five and here are
the pairings what do we like
ukrainian derby uh up top there i'm done
doing quite well and uh kiriel so far
not so much
uh yes
versus visually is clearly the game look
at this uh the
candidates the all candidates match up
on the fifth board yes uh fabi versus
richie fabi versus bishop
also you know on a normal day would have
been something very much to look forward
to and we have some uh interesting uh
interesting openings
uh kerosene is saying the grand prix
attack against
against korvo continues in the same way
and yet he is not going to back down i'm
pretty sure you know if we didn't think
that already we would have kind of known
after his game against vichy that he was
not going to
suddenly change his approach and in the
lavon game versus vichy uh again one of
these joko piano positions where he goes
the knight is on b8 and it's not going
to c6 i'm pretty sure oh this came from
the business this is a bishop ending uh
opening yes sorry and and vishy is doing
something clever here yeah as you can
see yeah he is he's just uh
very often in the italians you spend a
lot of time actually improving the
knight on c6 because it's by far your
worst light piece exactly so vicious
says i am not interested in spending you
know oodles a lot of time on that i'll
just develop it to d7 f8 right or d7 c5
and then e6 perhaps in some positions or
a65 but i think it goes to d7 in most
cases
uh so yeah it's it it should be it's a
very symmetrical position knight b7
actually leads to full symmetry right
now if black wants it you can also spend
the tempo on rookie 8 first because
maybe you want to play rook g8 bishop e6
and then 97 in some cases uh-huh just
asking yeah and this is this is what he
does yeah good call good call
the trade of bishops i always felt that
in these positions the light squared
bishop for white the b3 bishop was
white's best minor piece frankly and the
move bishop e6 i always found to be a
very compelling uh
way of playing yeah it does it does
become you know very italian in spirit
like bishop b6 i'm pretty sure we play
bishop c2 i don't think we allow that
trade not at all and uh yeah hp6 on the
board i'm pretty sure levon uh
is is going to play bishop city so if
you play something like knight f1 here
it's fine but i think you kind of
relinquish all hopes of any kind of an
advantage take stakes i would even throw
in a7 a5 here pretty early maybe even
immediately trying to fix that pawn on
b3 and then run knight bg7
um completely fine for black as probably
is the position of the bishop c2 as well
but bishop c2 does allow for slightly
more complicated positions i think we
can play knight bg7 now one thing to
watch out for for black in these types
of positions is you obviously don't want
to allow knight g5
yes with the bishop on e6 so i would
consider playing h6 normally but here 95
is so well met by by bishop g4 that we
don't have to spend the tempo on it yet
once white plays h3 though
and you're trying desperately to play f2
f3 but the computer won't allow yeah
you're right bishop g4 is a good answer
tonight yeah and instead of all this
yeah 11 immediately goes d3 d4 here and
doesn't even play h3
exactly and uh yeah this is very
inviting yeah this is very still very
kind of
italian ocean spirit but the the knight
already being on d7 not having to
reroute it to anywhere
should be fine for black feels like yeah
you're also ahead yeah also there's an
immediate move bishop g4 which like i i
don't know if the arrow is from here no
that's from my uh than the previous
position yeah that that's my but it's
actually very playable here and it it
might lead to very sharp positions
because it hd4 is an immediate thread
if you play knight c4 maybe not c4 is
though yeah because d6 is hanging
unfortunately and the six is hanging
after crazy lines like this um
you gotta calculate
you just have to start to calculate yeah
obviously not obligatory for black no
whatsoever no no no no
one question i have is can we actually
afford to play d65 straight away in
probably not
because after it takes d5 i have to
destroy i have to move the bishop away
from e6 and now we take with the knight
on e5 right
knight takes e5 takes e4 g4 specifically
to connect the queen on g1 with the g4
square
and after knight if after knight takes
e5 ge5
the fact that we don't have knight g4 i
think makes this
is disturbing yeah this makes this uh
not work for black but if you played
knight d7 now you would have marshall
gambit like compensation absolutely
thank you very much yes yes
right alejandro i mean
jump right on in
get out of here yeah you got a french
defense on yours and on your board
what's going on we do have richard
report in the tournament which is why we
have hopes for the french but remember
corabos also in it now after the move
queen g4 queen c7 the main move of this
position by far is 97 going into the
poison pawn winner
very sharp very theoretical not
something that richard is interested in
discussing with fabiano caruana instead
the move f6 was played and actually i
was looking at this not so long ago i
was trying to make the winner playable
for black again
i tried this once
players have gone before you alejandro
it's all terrible
it's like very depressing this research
knight f3 was played c4 and specifically
looking at this move c4
after 903 as an attempt to equalize the
game with black the ideas that you go
knight c6 and try to long castle at some
point quickly and you hold on to the
pressure on e5 try to see where white is
actually going to make progress because
if you take you're happy to take with
the knight in this positions the tempo
is pretty important but this queen h5
check move is actually super annoying it
looks like a waste of tempo because of
g6 but the thing is this pawn
is really supporting this pawn on f6 and
after queen h4 it's hard to keep all of
your dark squares
preserved in this position pontex will
come bishop g5 will come you're just too
weak and after queen f7 which is the al
the only other good option of blocking
the check you actually happily go into
the end game and go g4 and the idea is
that you take on f6 at some point you
don't have to do it anytime soon and you
go g5 when you force black to take with
the g pawn and then exploit the weak and
dark squares and actually this is a very
big advantage for white i
have looked at this before favi had
clearly looked at this before because he
he played the move g4 which is a novelty
instantly and after bishop d7 he is
having a little bit of a thing the move
bishop d7 is probably not going to
change the character of the position it
develops a bishop yada yada the rook is
going to come to b1 it's going to attack
this pawn this pawn on c2 is weak i
expect the bishop to jump to a4 at some
point to attack it this pawn will
probably be defended by a rook on b2 or
a king on d2 probably the king because
favi after some thought has put the
bishop on f4 already knowing that he's
going to target the e5 square after
taking on f6 one day and playing g5 he's
also giving his king room on d2 after
the bishop a4 so i can defend his
weakness and the king is not hemming in
the bishop the engines
love white's position but this is
typical for the french especially this
kind of french endgames the more you
play these lines you kind of realize why
they love this position so much it is
much easier to play with the white
pieces every opening of the position
also helps the bishops which currently
white has more of so
practical game difficult structure
objectively better for white
but it's a french it will have a fight
all right very good and
we've spoken peter about the beautiful
chairs the gamer chairs that uh the
players are having in warsaw but lavon
man he didn't have his mobility his
wheel was broken
he said hey
i need i need the sports just to clarify
not not his will the chairs will yes his
wheels are fine his wheels are i'm not
sure wait a minute we couldn't be half
broken his wills but yes he he needed a
change of uh chairs there
and he he got it so that that was why
the things are things
the play had been paused in his game
against vishy and none
but i was listening to everything that
alejandro was saying and
you know the move g4 being a novelty but
when you the presented in the way that
alejandra was saying at a certain moment
why is it ready to capture on f6 go g5
it's very clearly indicated by g4 yeah
take possession of the e5 square and
that will be huge uh richard did not go
for the
the counter play that usually
just solves all of it so easily that it
feels like a wasted waste of it
precisely that the king looks looks
regal we're playing we're playing king
anyway in most cases
so why why provoke it and that was why
richard in response played knight uh c6
yeah and i suspect i'm expecting king
jitto even here to be honest the kingdom
or maybe h4 asking the question if we
want to allow
h5 or if you want to play h5 ourselves
actually h5 h5 from black here is is
quite decent if we start with h4 h5
because i thought
my plan was to respond with respond to
with it takes f6 but then h takes g is a
very useful inter met so potentially
you can take this just maybe king takes
g7 and the structure gets kind of broken
up maybe even here white is better after
95 honestly yeah like the bishops are
about ready to take control
over the position um so h4 is definitely
playable but
other moves other moves are of course
possible you can you can play king ji2
you can maybe play rook b1 i don't know
why we're playing rugby one because b6
is a very comfortable response but maybe
just throw it in to have a rook on a
semi-open file even if currently it's
not very doing very much there exactly
plenty of options i i do agree with what
alejandra said that it looks it looks
like a reasonably promising end game for
white with the bishops and the
eventually the position will become open
and
i think actually one of one of an
additional reason to play g4 this early
i don't know how relevant it is but
the position is so closed that maybe
ugly as it sounds
black could consider playing f6 f5
closing everything down completely
with the pawn on g2 obviously not here
but
let's say instead of g4 we make some
kind of a normal developing move i don't
know
f5 looks unbelievably ugly to even
contemplate but on the other hand
it does close everything down very very
uh comfortably and the bishop on f1
you know bringing it into the game might
become
a bit of a challenge yeah it's not it
it's definitely going h3 directions so
uh
by playing g4 as early as white has done
we are saying he crosses
as ugly as you said it you described it
as being positionally uh ugly but i do
like this a g4 going back to our
tournament leader uh alejandra how's
vishy doing it's sharpening up let's
take a look at what happened in this
game we left it off in this position and
bishop g4 was your consideration among
other moves vg4 you guys liked because
of the pressure on the d4 square and the
tactical solution came with h3 here and
g4 levon saying i have to go for broken
this position otherwise the diagonal is
too annoying the bishop retreats to g6
and after taking on e5 you could take
with the pawn but after knight takes
knight takes you could still take with
the pawn in this position by vishy but
vishy thought this is the right time to
take with the rook rook takes e5 on the
board and now black has a ton of
activity the bishop is active these
pieces are attacking e4 but you're
constantly tactically worried about this
king disappearing from the diagonal so
that i could play f4 attack the rook and
f5 to trap the bishop so immediately the
problem for vichy will be what do you
reply against king g2 anything that's
not king g2 is just much better for
black huge strategical threat from black
the move d5 exactly it opens up the
entire center and you cannot take on d5
because i take only one take only one
bishop takes c2 at the end d5 is a huge
threat the the question is does it work
after king g2 because d5 i don't mean
with any of those moves i meet with f4
instantly attacking the rook and forcing
you to sacrifice something on e4 which
the edges think is a little bit better
for white but not that much better for
whiteness then the move knight c4 came
on the board attacking this bishop on b6
this rook on e5 this pawn on d6 but what
about the counter because the engines
are saying rookie 6 is good for black
but knight takes e4 immediately is much
stronger
you attack the pawn on f2
you cannot take on the rook on e5 i like
cannot do that i like knight e4 94 would
be huge because after bishop takes e4
you could just take on e4 and be much
much better the engine's thinking that
you can even take on f2 check that one
is a little bit wild let's take a look
at these lines check takes queen h4
currently down two pieces for black but
you're going to get back one on e4 kg to
the end just saying it's the only move i
don't really know why the other ones
lose so quickly but they lose and rook
takes e4 and black has huge compensation
for the piece in this position opposite
color bishops wheat king group coming to
e8 94 already on the board 94 on the
board but even though this is very nice
taking on f2 you could just take on e4
back and be much better and be much
better in this position
as black right so vichy with the
initiative with the advantage
in the fifth game here against lavon
ironian
about even time 20 some minutes for the
both players and vichy looks a bit
confused about what level is doing like
what's going on lavon's had like five
six lost positions that he's drawn video
i mean he's really pushing me really
good
extreme
but first of all let's uh jump to warsaw
and check in with anastasia and
christian
what's going on
thank
thank you uh yeah sir yes uh we were uh
hanging around with the players in
between rounds and actually anastasia
you uh overheard something tell us a bit
about that no i just wanted to mention
first of all that it's a really nice
atmosphere and after the game soul
players come to the nice area and they
just chat with each other and actually
just before the game we shanand and
leona renyanda where they had this
friendly child discussion and they were
talking about this famous russian soviet
let's say movie um probably peter knows
it of course i mean gentlemen so fortune
and they were like translating and
michael kodakowski was also
the part of the discussion so they had
really friendly chat and it was really
great to see them then
you know go and to play their game and
now we see it's such a mess on the board
and actually yesterday they were
chatting again with levon and wish said
it's better never to speak with levon
before the game so i don't know why he
broke this rule and he they were still
charging me for that so i mean it's
really nice to be here and see the
players even after the game analyzing a
little bit it's interesting that nobody
has computers with them so probably they
had all the preparation at home but
sometimes they check their phones and
they want to see if they made any
mistakes between the rounds some of them
they don't do that they just try to rest
so it's it's really interesting but i
think today it's a really nice derby
between ukrainian players i think he
really got some chances in his game
that one is definitely an interesting
one and you were mentioning they don't
check the computers actually i've only
seen one second uh that of yan shishtav
duda nobody else is here so they're not
looking at the engine they're just going
and playing and that's why we're having
all these very very exciting games
another thing about levon he was saying
that he's getting used to these half
miracles saving half but only for half a
point so he wants more he wants to save
this type of losing positions but win
them so he was a little bit disappointed
now visha anand is just incredible he's
in such a great shape right now again
with a better position against levon
right now with the black pieces this is
just incredible and uh this one the game
between caruana and a rapport i have to
say i'm very impressed with the way
rapport is handling the opening phase
especially against an expert such as
fabiano caruana 21 minutes for richie
only 16 minutes for a report and
another game that i was having my eyes
on is the one between uh gavri lasko the
romanian who right now is struggling
zero out of the four he needs uh to come
back from that and he's playing uh
vojtashek radoslav who also lost his
previous game against duda so this one
is a big big matchup what i told david
in between the rounds i told him play
faster just play more confidently and uh
try to keep the tension in the position
and
i like what i'm seeing from him right
now at least the position doesn't seem
as imbalanced i think he will be able to
calm down the waters and potentially
make a draw let's see what happens in
this one guys back to you thank you
anastasia and thank you christian i
especially like the interplay between
the players
before the games they really are uh
friendly but look at what lavonne is
doing
he just
blundered
terribly and this she is about to go
can you believe it five in a row baby i
think this is really nice night of the
queen is not what you want to see and uh
yeah yeah there's a number of ways for
black to be completely winning now i
think
alejandro expressed it better
best king g2 was basically a forced move
in order to play i'm very surprised he
hasn't seen it's just very very logical
and knight takes e4 threatening bishop
takes f2 knight takes b6 blunder two bad
moves in a row and look at what's
happening knight f2 you can't take on
that you took an h4 is resigned so yeah
he was forced to play queen g2 and now
vichy has a choice like queen xb6 is a
very very uh
technical rookie 5 knight takes g4 i
think is the simplest uh you have to
play rookie three i will just take on e3
with the knight and i will play some
kind of an endgame where i have pawns
and white doesn't
a lot of them a lot of them and why he
doesn't and why just doesn't uh so kind
of the economy takes place i'm actually
expecting kind of a handshake sooner
it's so
jump in
vaughn
you will not resign he will find chance
no way he doesn't find chances from here
not here
how many pawns are we talking already
right now it's two pawns but he'll be he
will be down three he'll be definitely
three
three in the worst position and no
weaknesses and no counter play and vichy
on the opposite side
at some point he'll play age six i mean
we we have a beautiful term uh fort knox
that's where we keep on gold right
and that black king
that looks like fort knox right now so
if you're in erroneous shoes and you're
saying where do i go
i'm gonna i'm gonna go after the king
well good luck with that i mean it's uh
it's not happening it's a it's a weird
one because you know it's so bad
i mean the material count is just
yeah i get it again it feels like black
should be missing a piece or something
right you take the rook
and then you start thinking like is this
interesting
exactly yeah i mean it's just so bizarre
black is also two pawns up right now
it's just
and by the way you know
if christian will invite vichy on set
and she will go like am i dreaming you
know could you please pinch me and tell
me you know i'm awake like i i this is
reality right and he has played rook
takes e5 and knight takes g4 yeah
vichy doesn't have to be asked twice you
you want to give me a third pawn i'll
take it
check yeah this is uh this is just
i haven't really i don't think i've ever
seen levon play as
weirdly and like successfully yes yeah
but also successfully as as here yeah
yeah
i'm not sure what i'm watching right
because this is weird right he is very
very tactically aware and like exactly
i have my biggest question like if we go
back to the position where he went
knight c4 yes it's a toxic tactical
oversight he clearly underestimated you
know slash mist knight takes e4
but you're still wars after rookie six
this is my point like
how do you
how do you come to this conclusion like
how do you how do you go for this
mission instead of king g2 because if
you play king g2 yes it's a mess but
it's a mess where like you instantly you
instantly realize you don't know who is
better right and if if the other option
the option you actually go for
like i mean he knows he's worse there
yeah it's not like he doesn't realize
he's worse it's just a question of how
much right
i just i i can't really figure out why
he would play knight c4 there and then
and knight b6 to follow it it all
compounds itself but the the starting
point there is you have a decent move
and you don't make it
despite your all your other options
being clearly inferior horrible
and their lifetime head-to-head matchups
in rapid chass again take a look these
guys have been around the horn and yeah
yeah
plus against against fish
generally has been a i think of
an unpleasant opponent
many people have that kind of a score
i mean if you said magnus had that score
i said okay that's magnus that one's
good levonny wow for me for me this is
always you know and the one king g2
all part of the plan all part of the
plan king's only down he's only down
three pounds okay now he will win the g6
pawn back yeah and then he will get
mated yeah
even having watched the you know the uh
book arrest and and now this i still
don't quite understand why he's i think
it's mainly out of
kind of annoyance and
you know frustration
and
gnashing of teeth and there goes the
pawn look at that just there you go now
he's only dominant
rook
rookie you can't even develop the bishop
this is so cool yeah b2 is hanging but
you know you you so desperately want to
play rook d8
um
that's what i mean
but now you
yeah no i mean everything won we don't
have to yeah we don't wow we don't have
to vulture this position yeah oh yes we
do
like i i really don't understand why
he's continuing i think it's mainly just
to get the swearing out of the system
yeah because like if you resign here you
have to go to the player's lounge it
will be empty apart from you right
nobody too you don't particularly want
to talk to yourself
and
and you're just doing they're extremely
annoyed and right and by staying at the
board you can sort of get some of this
out of your system exactly yeah like you
just resign here knight d3 very very
rookie a queen of five like you can you
can take the entire queen side of the
board i think black is winning like if
you remove a7 b7 and c6 bones off the
board here i think black is still
winning yeah but you like the pawn on c6
because you're going to put your queen
on d5 and it will be protected as you
said
very well you're going to get yourself
made it one of the
one of the things i was very happy to
see is in the game of anton
is i'm really getting disgusted by this
move bishop c4
i mean white is getting worse positions
in the open sicilian with bishop c4
instead we have the f4 yeah and we get
a normal shivan again which is kind of
fun yeah instead of the grand prix we we
ended up playing a line i actually
played a bit of this with white
some 20 years ago uh this line is sort
of more uh
there's more venom to what white is
doing than you than you and there you go
as expected levon did resign against wow
five out of five for the tiger madras
what a beast
wow yeah
well done vishy vishy again i mean you
know he's he's taken the sabbatical for
a few months he's as he's been saying
you know he's ambassador to chats and
working with the juniors you know in
shanghaiing and playing in blitz
and now he's back at the board and now
you see why he was such a world champion
i mean when he's in form
he's snap crackle pop
yep yep uh but what do you think of the
game of anton and kirill for a moment
because it is a lot of fun it is very
sharp and also i want to say that
i've watched anton play these structures
a bit
he is very very good at these types of
positions he he understands
material imbalances really well he's
very good at sort of
leaving stuff on praise and sacrificing
pawns and just changing structures kimbi
one is very very serious here actually
creates a threat of 95 and we can't meet
before with knight eight so
yeah this was the this is where i was
going with this whole thing i mean do
you think that this is a a dead end kind
of i mean black is trying to open up the
king side i think this works i think
it's actually i think with the bishop on
d4 controlling so much i just go e takes
d5 here first to to stop the
uh the chaos
and then i will take on before with the
knight yeah provoke bishop takes before
and uh i think i'm doing quite well here
with white i think in v1 could they
fight i'm
sort of somewhat surprised by and uh not
unsure i'm not not sure about at all
good reply here right well queen 85 king
b1
i don't like it uh should i thought i
thought about bishop b7 with the
intention of meeting knight g5 with
bishop d8 but i get the feeling you
might lose i get the feeling it might
lose but because after after bishop c3 i
will have to play queen a4 and i will
have to pray that this queen's clown
doesn't get picked out and after let's
say bishop before i'd be followed by b3
you know i'd be very reluctant to go
down this fast
the the
oh dear oh my gosh look at that
discrepancies and shares this reminds me
this is not fair this is and this is a
bad game this is what we have
what does it remind you there was this
tournament was it the candidates yes the
candidates yeah where everybody was
playing in this glorious chairs yeah for
sure bishop was playing well basically
an office chair no it was like a stool
it was basically a stool i think what
was here let's jump over to warsaw and
uh have an interview with our tournament
leader
let's go
thank you uh yeah sir vicious just
simply mesmerizing chess up to at this
point can you remember the last time you
started off with 5-0
um
at least not in the granchester um
yeah but this was a gift so it was he
just um
he just blanked out you talked with him
a little bit after the game what did you
guys discuss did he miss this move
knight takes e4 or
what was his miss no i'll tell you he
after d e5 instead of de5 should i just
type it yes absolutely he thought
he later on said he should have played
knight c4
and uh the idea was instead of the e5
yes and if i go
ed4 then he takes on d6
and um
if rookie six then knight f5 that is
correct yeah
but um suddenly i'm seeing that uh
instead of rookie six i can play queen
c7
c7 and if you take queen to g3 oh you
can just take it oh the pawn is still on
before
okay that's only still on this one yeah
so that was uh
so uh in fact this might be more
reasonable for him i mean i i was
surprised he went for g4 because i
thought i'm already better
but uh if i have to play bishop c7 then
it's entirely under control because he
no it does seem the taking and then
rookie
maybe take on c3 and uh
knight c5 or something that's going to
be okay for c7 he has some compensation
of course but actually there's no pawn
down so
it's just a normal position
uh and he played take on e5 knight takes
eve well this noise as far as i could
see he was just like he's just lost here
i mean i'm maybe i'm overly i also
knight d4 still wasn't clear to me
but um
i was thinking d5 f4 d4
no it's not that
that the computer likes
so what should i play here instead some
knight
takes g4 or something i mean i was going
to sit and think of it but i was
expecting knight d4 because i almost
thought it's only move
after knight e5 rook e5 i don't see a
defense firing if he goes king g2 i go
d5 and this is what he had
he missed at the end
so
and once again this computer is
irritating me by saying that i'm
completely wrong we both hallucinated
then because we thought this is game
over but now i see that rook f1 and
keeps white
is the only move that is embarrassing i
spoiled the mesmerizing
thing but um ah so we just both
miscalculated perhaps
and he panicked yeah we just missed rook
from the end because it looks like
otherwise white can resign you cannot
and uh
and somehow the problem is when you have
a bishop on g6 you don't think the f7
pawn is gonna drop
and so it a little bit of that oh so
king g2 is still playable then and then
um
okay so we were both we were both in
another world i mean i was surprised he
was surprised and then
he went for this of course
and now he should cut his losses and
take on e4 though already i'm not sure
that i don't have bishop f2 check
but uh the way he did it
it's just two designs i mean and three
pawns up for something so
no he just um
he just blew screen so that was it
everything is connecting perfectly right
now for you did you do anything
differently for uh this tournament in
preparation or is just everything
juggling together
i don't know um
i didn't do anything
very different
i tried to get back into shape and
i mean the first game the day was quite
good i think
there was a good
admittedly his e4 wasn't uncalled for i
think but once he did it i thought i did
a decent job maybe the only thing was
i needn't have allowed him b4 quite as
fast with knight d3
there were still some other moves maybe
if i play g4 or something i'd have been
even even happier with my play
but uh that was a good game this one
i think it's not lemon's level and i'm
not going to pretend it is
good vibes definitely a lot of
confidence for you vichy we're looking
forward to see you in the next game
thanks guys back to you thank you uh
christian thank you vichy that was a job
for those blue screens that was a very
good description yeah the the the fabled
the label bsod
blue screen and blank out but
exciting things are happening alejandro
and wesley so's game absolutely wesley
saw here with the black pieces against
duda they got to this highly topical
position that i've seen many times
myself this is of course a line of the
berlin with a quick d5 take to take with
the queen the bishop drops back to c4
this position has been seen many times
and everybody's played bishop a3
and i had wondered why not a5 trapped
the bishop and there's been tons of
analysis on why you should not play a5
and allow bishop takes f2 and some
complications that end up favoring black
now it is possible to say here as white
look it's a rapid game i'm gonna play
five let's prove it over the board i
have some analysis you have to be
precise as black the weird thing is do
that thought for 10 minutes in this
position
and then played a5
okay which to wesley
you know he knew he knows this opening
right he instantly took on f2 took on f2
took on d3 whoops a little misplay there
queen e2 and we got to this position
after queen takes where black has three
pawns already for uh
the piece and he's gonna take a fourth
one on b4 so after rook a3 queen takes
b4 we kind of quickly reached this
position do that with eight minutes
against 14 by wesley and we basically
reached an end game by force because
white's position was so weak that you
had to start shedding pawns and the king
wasn't able to develop we have a bishop
against four pawns but black is just
very active the knight is good the
knight is also coming to d5 at some
point and then you can start rolling the
pawns are gonna roll f5 f4 at some point
once i defend this guy this rook is
probably gonna come to e8 pretty quickly
and it's going to force white completely
into the defensive i don't think that
white is lost the engines love black
they do think it's a decisive advantage
i think that this probably is holdable
for white especially in a rapid game but
who's better it's obviously black and
the weird thing for me straight out of
the opening
exactly in a topical opening where you
spend 11 minutes to play a fight i'm not
i'm not sure what's going on here this
for a candidate would be a huge misfire
this is such a topical position
wow thank you for that and peter
sometimes you just get your prep wrong
it's but that's not how you get your
prep wrong like it's uh
the very very long pause before you play
a5 there
is is we it's something i would do
but i don't have prep so
you're a man without prep i understand
so
i can sort of understand how i would get
to that point right because like i would
not really know anything and i would
become curious because you know this
isn't that a piece there's a piece there
on b6 which i can capture by playing a5
so why not try it right but yeah
it's a very like for players who
actually play the italian seriously this
is one of the absolute central positions
even i can quote some lines at you if
you really ask me to and i don't play
with either color
pretty much so mentioning yeah uh yeah
it's it's so it's a weird one for sure
because yeah youngsters is very
well booked up these days and
you know
you you have to kind of
perhaps even wonder if we
need to start discussing the the the
fabled shall we
hide a prep
topic but
yeah it really doesn't seem like it it
seems like some kind of a strange
strange misfire as alejandro described
it
i don't want to engage in any
commentators curse but david
who has had a very bad start let's just
be uh complain about it he's got the
target on his back he's up against the
polish champion uh radically and he
looks like he's making a draw i'm not
exactly sure it's annoying though why he
didn't play g4
very annoying actually is it is it yeah
because i i wanted g4 last time i was
about to say he was closing in on a
drawback i mean g4 g4 last turn was much
better because it worked better tempo
wise right leave it on yasser's board
after g4 your threading f5 forces you to
take on g4 still black is a bit better
because outside pass pawns and stuff
like that but you lost this anchor
exactly you lose the anchor of the e4
knight if you go back to the position we
have on the board right now you still
kind of want to play g4 king f3 king d6
you still kind of wanna yeah black plays
king g5 right exactly but now you gave
me a free tempo to get the king to d5
defend on e4 attack the knight on d4 so
yes still should be salvageable for
white but you've made your life a lot
harder with this inaccuracy it feels so
good also something like knight d6 here
he has played g4
and he did it at tempo too soon uh to
improve too late pardon me uh david
making his life a lot more difficult
again uh i'd like to see this young man
and uh get on the board let's put it
that way yeah i'm on very very good
terms with radic and i generally support
radical and everything he does but you
do feel that
for you know for the rest of the day or
for the rest of the tournament it's kind
of important that
david doesn't lose this one because
exactly you lose the first four but
they're all fighting games and yeah as i
said like there were
there were glimpses there of
why
yeah good play and everything but if
then you lose a five against five night
ending that's not to go to go 05 that's
not good yeah it's really not very good
for his uh
mental state so i would i would like to
see him actually hold this i'd like to
turn the conversation back to our all
candidates match-up is this is a very
uh i want to say intriguing position at
least i find it to be the case between
fabi and richard um when we saw the move
g4
we as alejandro was explaining it to us
it was all based on this id premise that
we were going to take
after the pawn got recaptured then we
were going to play at g5 and thanks to
further trades the e5 square would we
actually
we were discussing the position
but what was curious was that after h5
takes and there's no longer g5
and the players got to a very
peculiar
blocked
mess and peter yeah watch out try to
break it down for us please white still
has the space and white i think has the
clearest single idea in the position
which is to play h5h6
and i think this is what rook h2 is
attempting to prepare oops because we
want we want the rook to not hang so
that h6 immediately creates a threat of
h takes g7
and uh
currently like if if i
make a move b6 on the board just to pass
the pass the move
if if you play h6 here
the question is whether knight takes h6
with the intention of meeting bishop
takes h6 with a 5 is playable oh
crafting
if this is playable then maybe h6 is not
a threat yet right because if you like
bishop to hg6 would be the way to
justify previous play if you go back a
couple apply like you clearly don't want
to be taking on h6 after h6 knight h6 if
you take with the knight
gh ef
black goes i mean unless this works
tactically because this this steel is a
very very concrete situation right right
we want to play with page five check
next king takes f6 loses an exchange to
b5 simply maybe get made it as well
and
maybe this works out and then we don't
need to calculate bishop h6 and uh no
knight takes h6s yeah i'm off and i
think that's why richie played his move
play the move knight e7
g8
i don't want to deal with any of this
business exactly and you defend f6
which is actually yeah quite a crucial
sorry yeah i i i was wondering why
honestly h6 wasn't even played with rook
on h1
and i think knight g8 would have been
the answer there as well i actually come
to think of it but could in that case
can't we hd rook h1 gh4 h8 and this is
why i put the knight on g8 so that's
good for you but
uh so what that you put your knight on
g8 i mean i still won the e5 square
which i thought oh yeah just like this
but it was all are you happy eiffel
knight of six you know it's just very
good i mean
alejandro could we play h6 previous move
yes
okay was it good yes
why didn't we do it alejandro we will
have america right now with chris and
carrillo after they came to explain why
we'll be answered h6 here was actually
super strong hg a huge threat because
you take and take on f6 this is not good
enough well obviously that's nice that's
not that's not good enough this is not
also not good enough because of what you
said takes takes takes takes on f6 you
cannot recapture twice that's dead so 86
was hugely strong you cannot take here
because importantly you take with the
knight and you have bishop h5 following
it up
that's just
brutal
none of this works h6 just plus a plus a
lot it's a lot real you force pawn takes
and that's such a sad move to make wow
so rook h2 was a little bit too fancy it
was fancy play syndrome after rook h2
and now after knight g8 you have trouble
making progress you start trading nights
but the moment you start trading pieces
in this position you feel like
something's gone wrong for white right
and you mentioned peter that there is
this long-term issue that white has that
the bishop on e2
this is somehow passive yeah this is why
you wanted to start opening up files on
the king's side as early as possible
while while it was on the table because
it does give your bishop only two
squares to participate in the game scope
yeah we were playing with page five
check in like in every single position
what you want to do wow okay alejandra
that's uh
wow i i i just don't understand how you
could not play h6 there when you
you you you you've been gifted the
position where it actually yeah and it's
because
you guys might be thinking wow these
commentators are so critical about not
playing h6 when he could he was just
preparing it but the thing is you've
done all of your position the entirety
of white's position is to play h6 right
so you play the moment you have the
chance yeah because you must
everything is your rook on h2 the knight
that was eventually that was on g4 the
bishop on e2 all of your pieces even the
bishop on f4 they're geared for you to
play h6
it comes to the crucial moment that when
you are able to play h6 you have to
execute it yeah breaking down
honestly honestly i think you just
missed knight g8 i think uh you he felt
he was helpless he felt that black black
basically is as prepared as black can be
prepared for h6 and he assumed he has
one more tempo to continue building it
up
and after knight g80 he's got knight e3
uh yeah rook gh1 is kind of not not the
direction
knight e3
knight and fe and the response from
richie is quite interesting because he
actually went f6 five the move we
not here but in general like it it kills
off much of your counterplay oh that's a
beautiful but it also locks everything
down oh that's a beautiful move f5
michelle the bishop on e2 really does
suffer
yeah you're basically saying
this would have been completely lost if
this bishop 192 was any other any other
minor piece right but it's still only
two it will it will not have any moves
in this game exactly
it's a big spectator yeah it doesn't
have a role
what a turnaround i mean that
that could that could make all the
difference in the world right there yeah
this is
difficult now for both players to even
do anything exactly exactly um
uh going around the horn uh i wanted to
just again i i'd like to see these
junior players doing well i want to see
david
getting on the scoreboard and i think
he's doing okay yeah
isn't he okay yeah
now he can play king d3 and knight can
you see another three check is a nice
restructuring there yeah for sure
he's finally chilling yeah
kind of pushing black a little bit
backwards on the back foot so that
should have been in a drawer all right
very good and uh wesley so uh
back over to you what
but this is this is
crazy thanks oh
well this is just terrible for white i
mean
yeah not a lot of fun knight on g4
currently currently is under severe
threat both
h5 and f5 are threatening to actually
win it so you have to create a square
for it i assume something like bishop i
would like to play bishop takes a7
because we're very good yeah
because you need to make room for the
knight yes but also we are you know
black has four four pawns for the piece
currently i would like it to be three
exactly and
but i get the feeling that it might not
work out
he takes it
and 30 by the way for duda so he doesn't
have a lot of time sometimes you know
you've got to look at the
forced awkward moves but that peter
you got a feeling that that's going to
get punished
rather quickly you have to do it though
you right yeah wesley just comes out of
a game that he was winning in so many
different ways and he did it
he didn't find the finish he didn't find
the finish right right the engines don't
think that he's that much better it's
just after bishop a7 yeah it's minus one
so it is better for black but not that
much better and it starts with the king
hot knight d3 check the king has to go
to g3 you go f5 f4 so all of these
things need to be played by wesley and
he didn't do it properly the previous
time right
oh wait a minute
yeah yeah you can't go up to g through
two
night of two now ah sorry i
for some reason i was thinking like 93
was the only possible square but uh this
bishop on a7
it's like from the grave right
yeah it which is over he goes there he
reaches across the board
okay uh king g foreign
yeah interestingly knight of two hasn't
been played yet i'm guessing he is
considering who takes d3 but that looks
so lost though oh yeah you just no like
you you shouldn't be considering yeah
i'm just curious to his box yeah right
oh he's done something
yeah yeah i found what he was thinking
about yeah he is
he fails what
well it's an understandable move right
but an invite it invites b6 it invites
taking the knight
rugby 73 or whatever no i take a knight
but rugby seven i i can very easily
imagine why you would but maybe c5
followed by three or something yeah and
just i mean wait a minute just
and there it gets his first full point
that he does draw his game against
remember that they are claiming a
repetition becoming a repetition the
game's in rapid count for double
well
well again our congratulations to david
i mean it's it's very very tough you
i mean even if he had five months of
preparation uh he he would be the clear
underdog but five days yeah it's it's
just not not easy at all you just get
thrown to the walls it sounds a bit
condescending to congratulate somebody
on making a draw with white but it's
important like
we've had people absolutely bombed like
really
yes hello
was about 2700 at his peak and while he
was invited to louvre and he
was he had an absolute nightmare and
he had much more experience compared to
david exactly uh playing in events like
this so yeah it's just it's just
important at some point to get something
onto the scoreboard to like tell
yourself i can actually play against
these guys i don't have to
uh you know suffer endlessly right
um again i just want to i i personally i
i'm finding myself stunned by
the decision to trade light-squared
bishops everything was i think i think i
can i can get behind it
you can
we were kind of running out of moves and
it was just so crazy if he believes this
whole if he believes it works out
tactically
you can definitely like the bishop on
the ea8 was kind of poor and also the
rooks on h7 and h8 if they don't
actually have the age file to look
forward to they look a bit silly right
i got a dream i got a dream to
bring the knight on i actually like it a
lot because in particular king b2 which
is what to fabi played is the only move
in the position i like it quite a bit
because i think now we can
uh we can trade rooks right i think we
can go rook g80 i was i was worried
about rock g8 or k7 but i think that's
probably playing for a loss
because i will play rook giovan rook hh1
and i will ask you
is this not me yeah if you if you prick
me do i not bleed this kind of a right
kind of a question you know okay so if
we can play rook g8 get one pair of rook
soft black is maybe slightly better now
absolutely no question but maybe more
than maybe maybe more than slightly yeah
i remember i had this exact ending
against anatoly karpuff and completely
killed him somehow
never mind i was one of my worst
nightmares i didn't win that i just
wanted to go back to our all um
the duda game the all candidate matchup
because i'm just stunned by this move
rook b1 alejandra could you take it away
for us rupee 1 was a great move and
wesley responded perfectly we were
thinking of pontics but after rook takes
on b7
c5 we thought okay this pawn is passed
but there's still the resource of rook
b8 in this position and the idea is that
after takes takes you're no longer
defending the square on e1 so after e3
rook takes e2 i have the move king f2 at
the end holding down that bottom this
pawn has gotten a lot faster in this
position so instead of taking the knight
correct is to play the move
c5 immediately which was actually what
wesley played without taking the knight
and then going e3 and the point is that
if you take on e3 just f4 takes
recreates the past pawn if you take on
an a3 rook takes e3 is made in one i
would like to point out sorry if you
take on e3
c3 is made in one
which is cute but stronger than f4
[Laughter]
slightly stronger goal of chess
i like the queens
that's the strongest i'm winning on that
one alejandro yeah checkmates sometimes
they're not there but the queen is a
queen queen
all right knight h6 was played in the
game instead but after gh rook takes d3
e2 rook b1 and you can kind of see why
you threw in the knight check so that
you don't take with check and that the
pawn structure in front of the king is a
little bit messed up but
this end game
it's just dead right you don't have
enough material as white yeah you'll get
a pawn that's weak on f5 maybe this
point is not going to die because bishop
b6 will hold it but it's also not going
to promote
yeah no rookie three check looks like
lights out rookie three check king of
two
k3 or f4 f4 i think my biggest question
is why the biggest problem is that
you're also the king is so unsafe that
you're also getting exactly exactly
linear linear matrix yeah and
13 seconds and there's the head shake as
duder recognizes rook a3 he likes your
move
yeah and the king is getting hunted
apparently
you go rook takes c5 but the like
no
you never hold that
you just knew that
with one h pawn maybe there is some hope
some of these
some of these end games are not that
easy but with with h pawns allowing you
to play h5h4 at some point and like
challenge the pawn on g3 without really
giving white the passer it's completely
completely lost yeah yeah well i just
just go
very far you know i've got an exchange
in three pawns against a bishop in two
pawns you're thinking well i mean it's
not completely yeah it's completely
honest
all right
wow a big uh
a nice wing for wesley
there should he
win this and what about the anton game
anton
we we lost track of anton well let's
take a look at this game as chef chenko
isn't time pressure he seems to be a
player that gets into time pressure in
all of these rapid games we've seen him
go down to seconds in many games many
games in this tournament and he's doing
that again 20 some seconds for kilchenko
anton korobov still with plenty of time
seven minutes on his clock a4 position
is a mess i think we could have paid
more attention to this game if we didn't
have such great stories fishy fishy
wesley yeah but it's still a fun
position uh you see this is some kind of
scenario
i think is a good is a good move i think
mike is fine now
the question is whether you know he can
handle it in 28 seconds and he is a very
very strong blitz player
uh kirill shivchenko he is uh
arguably his biggest success came in
that uh lindaras abby sponsored blitz
tournament after the ringer grand swiss
in which most of the players of the
grand swiss participated exactly
winning in a very dramatic fashion
because i think fabi was
basically a second away from winning the
whole tournament and then uh
height material blundered mate in one i
think against cairo in the last round
that's helpful
yeah which which does help
if you can get that to happen to you
right right um but by the way what i
wanted to say is in the current position
uh carol suddenly he's got
the
the passer he's going to be very like
two bishops a b c b two bishops b pawn
is hot to trot i mean this is great news
for carol fans yeah i think i think he's
fine uh
at the very least yeah maybe even uh a
bit better i'm guessing black is not
doing that poorly yeah
but why not significantly better peter i
think you probably can
if i put a bishop on d5 exactly sure but
i i i think we probably if we play
precisely enough we should be able to
generate enough count to play against
the g5 pawn okay to create
destructions but yeah i'm i'm taking
white here every day of the week
because i was thinking if you tried rook
f3 for example should bake c5
unfortunately wins a piece precisely
and uh
wow
varusian
is
expressing interest in the move king f7
that's a visual move bringing your king
out of the g6 yeah i think that's the
way to go and uh it's not very easy to
find i think i think there are
absolutely
yeah falls under the category of things
you can definitely miss in a practical
game and even then you you have to kind
of wonder if white just goes all in with
like before king of seven kings six b5
b6 and so on yeah uh
you can very easily lose like this with
white because if black somehow manages
to stop it you know
not be able to say or yeah perhaps not
even crossing to b6 somehow right you
are giving up the pawn on g5 for nothing
and then black has two connected passers
on uh on the king side but yeah it's
kind of a strange oh i thought i i
really i thought he was reaching he
grabbed the rook in the end but i
thought he was reaching for his king
there yeah and rugby rugby is a very
human decision here not even allowing
him before b5 i think you're worried
about the people and reaching good good
squares exactly yeah
in the meantime wesley actually
i think he's thinking alongside the same
lines as me like he's wondering whether
this end game with
uh and the three against two in the past
might be drawn yeah he's passed because
i think what happens there is
if you're not careful you might drift
into this famous end game with the rook
and the h pawn against the king and the
dark square bishop right which is
winning
but you have to know how and even if you
know how you don't win every single time
because you get you get mixed up it's
it's one of the more difficult technical
end games in in existence in particular
sort of considering considering how
simple it
yeah himself
i
looks
at
uh did wesley that in fact this position
is winning he will put his rook on a4 so
basically we never play g3 here we go h3
we put the bishop on b8 we play king of
three yeah and we keep the bishop on the
h2ba diagonal
yes black will eventually if they if
black wants to black will eventually
like get the king to e4 player four
player three yeah we put the king on g1
yes we abandoned the idea of protecting
the h-bomb we understand the h-bomb will
eventually fall right but then
that end game with the rook and the h
pawns i have a feeling the fact that
black has two is completely irrelevant
i don't think maybe it makes it
slightly either play h3 h2 uh it it's
possible it makes it slightly more
difficult even because you might need
those squares i think the king often
hides behind it in some positions i
think it's actually a lot easier to win
with two pawns because at some point
when you
i think
you can put a rook on g3 and you can
cross backwards
just to help our audience yeah let's
let's just what's the grand masters are
discussing
is a position where
white uh
uh ends up having let's just play h5
here and show them yeah well no the idea
is we're going to take everything off
the board these two pawns and this pawn
we're going to take these three pawns
off the board we're going to put this
black h pawn all the way on h3 and a
white king on h2 and we're gonna say go
ahead and beat me yeah the the point
there is that that actually very often
is a mistake and the way to win that end
game is not even to play h5 h4 i think
uh you're supposed to keep it
on h4 for white and h5 for black if i
remember my uh my classic yeah yeah h5
yeah correct so
it crosses eventually yeah but it
crosses very very late for
for you to to win comfortably there so
we're anticipating that black will bring
his king to e4
he will put his pawn on f4
he will be able to trade
the f pawn for the g2 pawn and somehow
he'll win upon on h3 you win the pawn
because you're mating white basically
right so you have to you the h pawn has
to go somewhere
yeah uh but i i just wanted to i i i
i did this long-winded explanation and i
started talking about it even earlier
when we didn't even have this on the
board because they're reaching the
position you were talking about yeah for
four amateurs who perhaps have never
seen the same game before it looks like
the most trivial thing in the world like
why doesn't he why doesn't he resign
basically yeah
victor gorge knights
but
but
yeah rook rook and the rook of the uh
rook pawn against the bishop of the
opposite color like the the dark square
bishop with the h pawn or the light
squared bishop with the a pawn is
actually trickier a lot trickier than
you would suspect
and uh
very understandable that young shisht of
here this may have no this i thought
this would have been a surprise uh to
give up the key
because of diagonal we kind of where is
that rook by the way on c1 yeah
okay it looked a little bit uh it's skew
it's on c we see one and a half but c
one and a half yes yeah but you still
sort of and
she won enough to not really have to did
this did you see enough
did you see that okay so we're looking
at for example a move like uh
f4 right yeah just to throw it down
there well white i think goes bishop b8
okay of it doesn't matter it doesn't
shouldn't shouldn't matter and this is
where although you says you can try
restricting the bishop and getting king
e3 exactly but this is going to play it
crudely yeah this is the endgame this is
the end game exactly now take us from
here peter how
how do we how are we supposed to go
about winning this please don't
look that's the funny part right that
should be the easy part of the end game
right
okay so we're going to put our rook on
g3 like champions right yeah first of
there is king h2 there but let's show
the entire thing like let's not even
let's not even go king h2 right let's go
bishop b8
after g3 yeah so we don't want to take
the rook because that's the last king of
planet games so we just we just say we
chill yeah and this is the end game i
was talking about here it looks it looks
like it should be very very trivial to
win what are we talking about but as a
matter of fact
because
uh yeah but this is probably where the
h7 pawn comes in right this is where it
becomes easy because we play
uh like we put h we push h3h2 and then
we get into those positions so we go
like this
yeah let's do it in the nice ways yeah
let's put the rook on some better square
right okay we take it away we tickle we
never like leaving our rooks on dark
squares so we tickle the tickle we go
edge too do we go or king g4 yeah with
the second h-bone i think let's
oh yeah let's go king g4 first yeah
let's go okay first and we wait yeah we
go h2 yep and uh bishop bishop takes we
kind of
yeah we rock bishop takes king h3
okay bishop g1 and now with without the
pawn on h7 this is a draw because white
has stalemate ideas and you can't
actually win this position but with the
pollen yeah this probably is quite quite
easily winning so the idea is that as
alejandro says you get to play check
against the bishop
and you drive the king out of the corner
and you make it easy and then yeah and
then it becomes easier yeah it still is
shockingly even that is not still work
because i play bishop c7 here let's say
in this position
weirdly even this is not game over
because you can't remind me why the pawn
had to be on h5 i remember it has to be
on h5 and not on h4 and h4 it's a draw
there's some there's some reason yeah
i can't really give you anything apart
from this there's some reason
okay well we're definitely deep into our
classics guys and uh
this
is one thing like currently it says on
our screen that it's basically made in
18 or something but
h5h4 here and i think it's a draw on h4
i think it's because you have to put the
roof on g4 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is the reason
this is what i was talking about yeah
this is winning that's an easy mistake i
think the way you win this is you put
the rick on g4 and somehow when the
bishop can't give a check you go king h4
g5 you bring the king yeah you you you
you uh
uh harassed the bishop long enough to
kind of dominate it uh somehow such an
extent such an extent now you want to
bring your king out the king needs to
come out without allowing people into
the corner without allowing the king to
cross back into the corner and without
allowing the check to the king on h4 yes
all of that needs to happen so so the
idea is to get a dream position
something like this
and why is it the fact that our king can
come out so important because then
you're just pushed upon you're playing a
five here you're playing like you bishop
somewhere you're playing a five right
and then you start pushing h5 h4 h3
group g2 and you win that's clear yeah
that's very clear but yeah wow wow that
is really a long-winded yeah i like this
is because of banco
bencos palpatine and goes in secret lab
and game secret lighting column
magazine i love that i love that column
it's it's truly truly was very good
pal was uh
powell's
end game laboratory that's what it was
palestinian laboratory yeah
yeah
you know i once uh
oh h6 i once uh
spent an entire day at the manhattan
chess club where pal benko was like
regaling
this audience uh with his endgame
studies
i mean
he should have been selling tickets it
was so good uh what's going on in peter
in the fabies game with richard report
again this is a very important assuming
yeah black somehow lost the b7 pawn but
white lost the e3 pawn how did that all
happen
i mean
uh somehow this ending i would have
thought was better for black but
it's become
better for white i mean it's kind of a
curious move this last move rook f7 it
actually by force loses a5 but
i don't i mean there's no danger for
black anyway yeah it doesn't doesn't
really matter
holy smokes uh
yeah he's got knight g8 and then rook f7
you can take take play bishop b6 but
it's still completely fine for black
because the protected passer on a5
secures everything your extra c2 pawn
isn't that great very good
let's go back to wesley uh for a moment
oh yeah wesley actually got something
that he was not supposed to get and now
you're winning very clearly yeah yeah he
was not supposed to get this he got much
more than he's supposed to because now
he's getting through his f5 pawn yeah
the that's the thing right yeah the
bishop needed to be on the a7 g1
diagonal so that this didn't happen look
rook b6 g6 now ends the game yeah yeah
yeah very nicely done this is why he was
postponing a
foreign because yeah this is the
absolute sort of best case and but it
really isn't supposed to be
achievable yeah uh you're
white is white is not supposed to allow
it
yeah
yeah
they rookies
right yeah
rookie sexes resigns yeah i like i like
rook g6 better
you like forcing g3 and then
g3 and then we win in any way like in
any way we like
see i mean to be a good
grandmaster you have to be a bit of a
sadist let's face it you
you you kill kill kill and you keep
killing you need to be a killer
alejandro yeah well said yeah
the only way
it sounds a little cynical but i mean it
is true yeah i mean and we also have the
the the ukrainian ukrainian school is
still going on and
i hate when people do that right like
especially
then he took his rook back especially in
a position where everything is winning
and every you're just waiting to resign
and your opponent does that it feels so
bad he's like oh man what could he see
there that he would dislike that's what
dude was thinking too it's like
i mean i was ready to resign
don't understand
i don't know
honestly
like if let's say i play bishop b8 here
you go rookie too i go king g3 rook if
roojie took a f4 i like this one less
and the one with the with the king
completely locked in on h2 i i don't
like i don't like giving this king you
know any any breathing space i think
you're making a very good point actually
uh was that a good point no because he's
saying look if white got to play
king f4 kf4 rook f2 you put the ball on
f3 the guy resigns i mean yeah the guy
right if you go rook g6 and forces
play g3 now the king
never has a say i give a check from me
too i go king of two king of three i go
rogue rook takes g3 like that the king
will stay on h1 for the rest of the game
and i will just collect everything i
don't understand why this is not cleaner
i underst i also understand it's
completely irrelevant but yes everything
i like precision but i also like you
what you're talking about in terms of
counter play why give your opponent any
any hope whatsoever yeah with the king
on h1 there will not be a single shred
of hope for the rest of it and by the
way we do have a draw in the game of
anton
that looked like a game that was
full of vim and vigor sorry to both of
those players that we didn't get a
chance to spend
time on them but whoa whoa
things are changing in the game with me
can we can we go yeah this this really
isn't very exciting anymore yeah oh
let's jump over here bobby perhaps
thought that he won a piece with bishop
of six and knight d6 yeah he must have
blanked completely because he's oh he's
panicking right now oh
well he's saying 94.92
but this one changed dramatically it
sure did really well also this pawn got
twice
okay the pawn is going to go to d7 no no
sorry no no i cannot go to d7
but the 7 king c7 was probably annoying
yeah right so yeah i think
but yeah wife is in trouble because rook
we're not really i mean
we go rook of three rooks e3 right we
this is the threat and then
we get another pass passing
oh my gosh this game has had how many
lives is this uh
this game keeps giving a storyline
okay
uh king c7 you have to take on a5 you
have to take on it
rook f3 and yeah go back to asics
rook c3
you you get the phoenix you could play
king d7 i mean i could but i don't
particularly want to
you don't want to maybe i don't know
okay
you don't want to you don't want to rook
takes c3
the engines are pretty adamant about
rugby f5 rugby too
or or check and then rook b5 rook b2
that's fine too okay but then let's do
it that c2 needs to be defended it is
the base of your structure
and we just uh we just toss it away
three
and we get a three versus three versus
two would you suffer but well this one
is probably the best version right
i i don't know i i mean i guess
whoa
whoa what is going on he played king b7
really inviting rugby five check and it
still wasn't played
and now you would assume this collapses
yeah i don't think this holds this does
not hold not even close yeah yeah this
looks lost yes yeah because now when you
take on c two you just already created a
connected pass pawn
yes and then also the rubicon c5 is now
very stuck like if i if i go
if we continue the line there roxy three
king of two rook c2 king e3 and i just
go roxy to b2
rook
and nothing moves like nothing goes
anywhere
and you have to shadow zukswan as uh our
producer tom
seems completely lost to me like just
completely and utterly lost yeah this is
hopeless rugby three g3 is a threat or
if you go king for rookie to e4 takes d4
is a threat like that yeah
at this point you just winning that's
just gone however you want it right
let's just go on
well fabi has no choice he has to take
the pawn on f2
he could throw a check no he can't
because rick takes it to defensive too
yeah
i i ask you three yeah i like rugby two
just not allowing rupee five i love rook
b2 i think repeater is a boss oh yeah
yeah that's a great move yeah it's like
a6 most other movies takes a6 yeah like
i expect roxy one also to be winning or
even king a6 maybe to be winning but
yeah but yeah i like the idea of giving
experiences i really like the idea of
not not giving any squares to any of the
pieces
rook i mean i'm not saying i'm confused
by this move seriously he wants rookie
steroid d3 i mean he appears he's a
material man he wants the he wants three
connected passports okay but then what
do you do after check king h6 i think we
just win this way yeah yeah king a5
because you do pick up d4 by and we give
it four
and that's it i think yeah and this is
the one we were getting in the other
line as well it's completely dead
because the passers just they very
famously queen themselves like you go
rookie forking f6 you take on d4 you go
rogue g3 c3 g4 it's slow but it's steady
progress whoa
by the way the the move rook f2
that's pretty good
that is quite good it's quite annoying
yeah if king g6 rook f4 if king g4 you
go rook d2 immediately yeah you don't
actually oh that's nice
that that that's nice that also is yeah
that is very cute yeah
i i just wanted to say that i had asked
tom our producer if he had any advice
for fabi and he said
don't fall into zooksong
yes
tom has the concept
down a huge swing
in this game for for rit
in richie's favor uh
where did it all go wrong uh alejandro
it was that knight d6
well knight d6 already was better for
black but the enemy really fell apart
with this final move uh a5 i was
mentioning that you have to bring the
rook back and it was still holdable if
you go check in this position here in
rook b2 it's i was going to say a little
ugly it's really ugly you take on c3 you
might even have to give up a4 but as
long it just kind of works out for black
for white if you play king a5
immediately
i play rk2
i know yeah yeah i know but you have to
hold on to your to your uh pawns if you
move the rook up and down the board i'll
just do the same thing with my rook i'm
not going to move my king and if you
move your king i'm going to push my pawn
clear so you have to take on c3 at some
point you got to buy the bullet and you
take on f2 and this configuration is
massively ugly rook h3 gives great
winning chances you can play rook h4 try
to attack c3 as well you might even win
a4 in some variations but it's still
these two pawns against these three you
haven't created a connected passport at
any point you haven't created a passport
at all and because of the structure
white still has holding actually the
engine thinks it's a draw but in a
practical game i still would consider it
just as holding chances for the white
side but certainly it was back here
where i think favi thought he was
winning
in this position with jack king c6 and
bishop e7 here attacking this knight on
the eighth which is running out of
squares because if you go to b7 i mean
it's horribly trapped but more
importantly after bishop g5
if you take on c3 rookie 7 you're going
to be taking
this important pawn on e6 and then this
pawn is going to be promoting instead
the knight goes to f7 where it's
controlling the bishop and if the bishop
goes anywhere random like let's say
bishop h4 you could take on c3 the
engines are giving the weird king d7 so
that you hold on to e6 but the game
would have continued i just think he
thought he was winning after the move
bishop f6 because it hits the knight
and it seems like it doesn't have
squares but
and the reason i say that he missed it
is because 96 is absolutely forced in
this position it's using the fact that
the bishop is now hanging and finally
the knight is coming in with a huge
threat of 94 and 92 and favi thought
after this move he didn't instantly play
after knight d6 pawn takes d6 which is
the only move that doesn't lose
instantly so he must have been shell
shocked by this move knight d6 changing
the character of the position he wasn't
able to psychologically recover made one
more mistake down the line in the end
game this is already unpleasant to hold
and just wasn't able to hold on to his
draw and with uh christian we have the
romanian champion david gabrielescu in
warsaw
thank you alex alejandro we are indeed
here with the romanian superstar david
gabrielescu after his first draw of the
event david first of all how does it
feel to be facing all these world
superstars uh first of all thank you for
having me christian uh it's a very
amazing tournament i am very glad to be
a part of it and i hope i could i can
play better in the future and i can
make better results still a big
opportunity for you what uh how did you
handle the news that you will be playing
in this event i was extremely happy of
course i was actually playing in the
bundesliga in the um
in the weekend before the tournament and
i just
saw it like
i just finished the game and had to run
to the airport and just come here but
it's of course uh
it was a very nice news and i'm very
happy to be here you didn't have uh much
time between the bundesliga and the
start of this event how did you adjust
the strategy uh to play in this event
well of course it's very hard to prepare
against these guys so i just try to
repair my repertoire and figure out
where would be my weaknesses and try to
improve on that doing that in the few
days i had and
i hope that i had i did a nice job and
uh i could get nice position well let's
talk about uh this last game of yours
the one uh against voitashek uh
difficult start for you in the first
four rounds
what was your attitude your mindset
going into this game against rather slow
well of course i was trying to push for
a win to come back into the tournament
it was really tough the first few games
especially with so many blacks
but i'm trying to
get back on and i tried to push this
game but unfortunately i didn't quite
get the opening
position i wanted so
it was quite equal i think
out of the opening after i'm not sure
when did the uh theory i think about
here knight beat takes d7 and here i was
not sure i mean i i think i have to play
b3 because rook c8 and b5 will come
right along and here i was not quite
sure bishop b2 is of course the most
natural and here i wasn't sure if this
is necessary probably it's just uh just
equalizing but uh queen e2 maybe he even
has b5 i wasn't sure maybe i just take
and uh yeah i i wasn't sure if uh here
we are
complicated yeah probably my a6 pawn
will be pretty strong oh queen e1 was
really strong queen to e1 yeah i missed
that that's a difficult yeah that's
really nice because i like to see five
uh yeah yeah and also rook fc8 knight c6
i think is the idea and uh i'm just
winning actually
one apparently
okay this is this was not really really
in my calculation this is why in 95 i
thought is the easier approach but
probably just minimize my my advantage
okay advantage just because of my uh uh
advantage uh phone structure yeah
structure and the literature
but
it was not quite sure here i couldn't
stop d5 and i think here okay
of course the
most complicated is it takes it takes e5
94 maybe f4 but i thought my pawns are a
little bit shaky there and uh his 924
would be pretty strong so i thought that
maybe there i'm risking and i thought
that is not really a need for that so um
i simplify the position
is probably just a draw till the end
didn't feel like there was much
happening no it's it's probably just uh
yeah
every piece is
is matching and uh it's just a draw
you're playing uh wesley saw with the
black pieces in the last round of uh
today how are you going to approach that
one i would try to equalize from the
opening i know wesley
is playing mostly d4 now but he can of
course try to
try everything these players have a lot
of tools in the opening and i'll try to
equalize first and then
see what the position can bring me and
maybe push for more excellent we'll let
you go get your preparation going and
we'll see you in just a few minutes
thank you
and we will be going into a commercial
break stay tuned and we'll be back
shortly
[Music]
welcome to our show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys gonna see
[Music]
now go this yourself this is
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the final round of the
day today
we are nearing the end of day two of the
super bed trapping blitz in warsaw uh
so far we're witnessing
an incredible return
of the tiger madras let's take a look at
the current standings peter
yeah and there you have it wow
that's perfect yeah that is an actual
three point lead
five out of five
you're over richie where did he come
from he'd just be
well he he won yeah he won two games in
a row so far today yeah he he bit gabor
lesko in round one and then he beat fabi
with black which is uh some more
difficult designation
i would suggest yeah
so in third yeah wesley also having a
nice day young system started by winning
and then lost that game to wesley a very
strange game which we spoke about on
stream so no particular reason to go
back
uh over that ground
but let's uh take a look at the pairings
for the last round of the day yeah peter
the honors yeah let's start with
vishavishi is playing white against
young
who just had a kind of a nightmare on
the white side against wesley so the big
question is is the impossible possible
you know can you actually go 12 and 12-0
we are about to find out but apart from
that apart from that anton korowa is
white against creature upward a very
nice game two two very very exciting
players could be could be very good to
watch uh radicals white against fabi uh
wesley is playing against david
gabrieles who finally got his first
point on the board yep and the the young
ukrainian kiril shivchenko is playing
white against lewanda onion and there we
have it and they are off
more french more french i mean i think i
went a solid two years without casting a
french and this year
i can i can't think of many
what's going on what's going on why is
the french making a revival
right
and vicious sticks to his guns and goes
with the advance something he has
already used in this tournament to beat
anton korobov in the last ray in the
last round of the day yesterday so
nice nice symmetry to it
destroyed korobov so i want to i want to
see this one there's been a lot of
theory developing in this particular
every time we watch him he's somehow
playing white why is he playing white
someone what do you mean just getting
white
what he did against anton earlier in the
tournament on the white side of this was
pretty impressive yeah but m6 is
slightly different to what uh to what
anton did yeah
we could have a very very different game
on our hands because arguably the main
move in this position is c5 c4 there are
obviously other ways to play this
position but
c5 c4 at least used to be the way they
played
absolutely and they quickly played for
knight a5 and this this leads to very
very strange positions which should be
better for white but i think are very
difficult to to navigate properly and
could be quite double-edged or you could
play bishop d7 which after let's say b4
cd4 cd4 and uh rook c8 i think is the
main move in that position exactly is a
whole other
kettle of fish yeah no question and it's
remarkable how different the two lines
are i mean just like i i've had uh games
as on the black side that actually went
like this and i i was trying there is
this theory settled my knight in on the
c4 square and that's a very different
variation from c5 c4 yeah but c5 already
played by youngsters yeah on knight
tonight a5 as you as you mentioned right
white generally has more space
but black's position is very very solid
i do remember a world junior
championship where artur yusuf off on
the white side
his opponent
oh nerd egregiously
97 and archer to clip this pawn
and i came to the board many moves later
and it's a complete disaster for black
well that was one tree unsurprisingly
what happened uh this is how you could
ease quickly lose the game as
black if you uh blunder and the knight
lands on the d6 square which is why we
have the move uh c4
and knight a5 yeah but we should
probably let this one do for a bit
because this will be one of the slower
ones uh to
develop out of the opening we have a
king's indian on our hands with richard
play wonderful once again richard
playing the king's indian
but successfully yeah but not the
classical one he hasn't played 96 in
this one i wonder uh whether he really
disliked what he got or he just wants to
shake it up a little bit knight a6 d5 is
a bit surprising to me
i want to say that
like this isn't really supposed to be uh
all that much i used to play uh in my
king's indian playing days which weren't
very successful and they were quite a
long time ago but
uh when i played the kings indian i
played knight b7 not knight a6
but uh the movie is d45 there precisely
because of what we're watching on the
screen right now because it allows you
to play knight c5 hitting uh the pawn on
e4 and following it up with a7 a5 always
felt to me like a very very
you know
non-critical way to treat those
positions you're not challenging yeah it
seems like about
close to the ideal scenario for black
but even here and anton is playing very
very quickly obviously he
uh has ideas here you know even even
here you're maybe one temple short like
what we're watching on the screen right
now is if you could play bishop d7 and
a4 here with black i would suggest black
is better right clear
because pushing b5 before also b2 before
becomes pretty much impossible uh the
pawn on e4 is not going to be
too weak and if you want to go after it
like it will take five tempe to even
create a threat against it but
unfortunately for black uh if you play
a4 here you lose it on the spot
i think i've seen people do it yeah
which is uh i think i've seen people do
it yeah knight takes a4 and something
like h6h5 here with or or just going
back to the uh more standard but you
you're right h6h5 and
i don't
necessarily believe the pawn sacrifice
at all i mean it doesn't it's not
instantly made
obviously and if it's not made and the
other option is what rehearsal has done
he's played bishop d7 but then you have
to allow before
uh and i assume you play knight b7
without taking on bishop d7 on the board
and he did play before yeah but of
course he played b allowing before of
course
of course
and now
i'm
i'm guessing you go might be seven
knight b7 yeah i'm guessing you go
knight b7 white goes
you can play the immediate knight b3 you
can wait for it
uh something to be said also uh peter
for the immediate c5 i mean
uh oftentimes you want to get in your
queen side play very very very forcing
in one case we saw
black sacrificing upon another case we
could see white sacrificing upon yeah
but i think the amount of material that
will come off the board if you play c5
here i'm pretty sure i'm supposed to get
everything off the ball so i will i will
start with a b i'm pretty sure i need to
start with a b
i will take on a1 yeah i will take on c5
three times
three times
yeah
and uh black shouldn't be doing so
poorly and you'll take three times
apologize not at all
incoming
and something like this there's
definitely compensation for the pawn but
it doesn't really feel horrible i will
play queen e7 rugby eight bush buffet 27
rpa bishop f8
and uh away you go yeah i mean it's it's
i'm pretty sure it's fine for white but
it shouldn't be bad for black either
yeah
okay well let's see what he did by the
way he played c5
and so we might be uh going down at this
primrose path and we'll
let the players get to it what do you
have for us alejandro we didn't have to
wait a long time for this french to stew
because take a look at what happened we
did have the moves in this game between
anand and duda knight a5 rook b1 hinting
that you want to break open with the
move b3 this has been a plan for a very
long time and the move bishop d7 was
considered to be the
anti
plan of b3 the idea is that if you do
play b3 which is played in the game you
take on b3 actually b4 was played in the
game c takes b3 knight takes b3 is
possible c4 had been essayed once by
mirozovich against vaganyan in a
fascinating game but why even though
white won that one it was a little shaky
c4 hasn't been considered to be good for
a long time and since then this
variation kind of died off and everybody
started playing the move bishop e2 or h4
or something along those lines castling
preparing b3 later
but we're going to go straight into it
and you can see now the spin bishop on
a4 to the queen on d1 tactical problems
there was some analysis done
theoretically on the move knight fd2 i
did see it in a couple of books more
than one person mentioned this
knight fd2 rook c8 with plenty of play
for both sides uh but
knight takes a5 is vicious idea here
after bishop takes
d1 it is an exchange sacrifice check
this out take stakes black is currently
up in exchange if they take on d1 i can
always take on a5 you take on b7 the
knight's gonna get trapped the point is
to go check on b5 and the king doesn't
have great squares because if you go to
g5 then you take on b7 here
king takes c5 and then i have the tempo
to take on d1 i basically gain a free
pawn not the most important pawn but a
free pawn king e7 king takes d1 is
played instead and b takes a5 is
currently on the board and currently
black is full exchange up but what is
the problem king on e7 are very well
developed look at the coordination of
blacks pieces that being said no queens
on the board so it's hard to actually
checkmate the opponent's king the edges
are saying there is compensation but
probably not enough to actually get an
advantage not even equality here for the
white side you can imagine rook is a lot
of material so
very aggressive play here by vichy
sacrificing an exchange going into a
weird end game the engines are not in
love with it
and of course this would be a refutation
of the entire setup for black if this
works right so you know for all the
french players out there they're hoping
this doesn't actually work out
theoretically right it is an exchange i
don't know how you're going to use it
anytime soon we know that rooks are
pretty clumsy in the french
i think they're clumsy pieces in general
but in this particular case you can
imagine one day the position will open
up one day the rook is going to be worth
more than that bishop on b5 it might
take a while but what threats is white
planning on creating until the wild
comes and as we've seen a4 a4
f6 to be honest well he was intimating
bishop a3 check so he had to deal with
it because that is fair yeah i because i
thought f6 was mainly to do with the
fact that
before you play king g8 you do need to
secure the f7 pawn correct yeah i've
absolutely blanked on the edgy of this
play three check actually winning the
bishop
yeah yeah
yeah i wanted to play h6 h6 yeah and
and a small reminder that duda is one of
our candidates he's going to be heading
over to spain alongside fabiano carona
and richard rockport
and gary kasparov in an interview with
christian famously said that he expects
that the challenger to come from one of
these three players that's a bold claim
because i was about to say the field
gary
you know considering the top two
seats of the candidates are not in this
tournament
so f7 weigh in on this position uh of
peter because
it is a full exchange and obviously
all of black's pieces are on the back
rank but you know give him a move or two
f6 97 rook c8
and is it worth an exchange
i would like i would start by saying no
but this is also a vicious game
remains one of the one of the people in
in the world of chess who has sort of
the most ideas about everything
so i really really am not expecting this
to be entirely ad-libbed uh and so ideas
like if you put your king on f7
something like this although it allows
rook a6 it doesn't actually win the six
pawn well it's a good thing why does it
win
i like g4 because you start seeing
patterns in chess right i mean g4 what
does that immediately remind you of the
previous game previously
against richard rapport the same idea
the same structure you get g4 you take
on f6 you go g5 you break open that
structure you get the e5 square same
ideas same structure
same type of french a lot of different
resources around the position that are
different of course black is up the
exchange wasn't up the exchange in the
other game in this one the queen side is
completely locked down there's no bishop
coming to a lots of different ideas but
the structure's the same and we still
have some of the main ideas g4 i love
the move
without rookie one king
he heard you uh without rookie one like
me but uh he started with g4 he started
with g4 yeah
and i would expect the king
to go to f7 nonetheless
yeah yeah quite likely uh are you feels
like this is how you start developing a
piece you have to
do
do you want to do this i don't know if i
want to do it immediately because after
bishop e7
or g7 maybe i'm feeling that i'm helping
black a bit yeah and any captures i'm
kind of happy that the g file
opened up on a good day i'm just going
to go 97 knight f5 and put a rook on g8
and say okay you know
i'll i'll land on g2 one day uh yeah
more more looks more better
more looks more better okay we'll keep
an eye on that one let me just uh jump
on over to the game of lavon aronian for
a moment because
that's a different mess yeah that that
doesn't uh
they they got there by a different like
a kind of a fancy move order which i
haven't seen very much
um
but
it feels to me like i associate the
structure with the name of michael
chigarin for for some reason and
generally since the turn of the you know
previous century i think it was sort of
well understood that if you allow black
to meet d4 specifically the way uh levon
met it in uh in this game with this
setup of f6 d6 and the knight on d7 it's
it weirdly becomes very very difficult
for white to make any progress at all in
the center because e5 is absolutely the
bowler black's position and the legend
of three specifically like if that knife
was on some kind of a better square you
you probably would be slightly more
optimistic about white's chances but on
f3 it is so well controlled by that
uh triangle of pawns on d65 and f6 that
you you will struggle to you know
nominate a plan
and yeah levon is seemingly uh
reasonably comfortable here i would
suggest okay if the knight goes away
from a4 we can include the a5a4 as a
kind of a source of additional
counterplay if you even if all it does
is it trades the a pawn for uh
was weak yeah it was it was the one
weakness that perhaps white could play
against long term and now it's gone and
black does have the pair of bishops um
so it looks like lemon is completely
fine here at least uh
at first glance okay cool uh let's just
uh again sorry that was the fishy game
we're gonna jump to the wesley
so a game versus
david david just david making his first
a point if i can put it like now
um
slightly better for wesley
always going to be a bit better for a
while too right because of you know the
more active pieces exactly yeah yeah but
but extremely solid structure and whoa
what is this one
this is a catalan yeah it's a funny
handling of the catalan that i haven't
seen before
okay uh
alejandro jumped right in so this is a
standard catalog but i've never seen a4
i've seen the idea of a5 but i haven't
seen it with the idea of a4 queen a5 and
then playing the move b6
fabi
uh
showing his prep
hopefully not his candidates parker this
is just kind of ugly
uh
i mean the engine thinks it's fine but i
think it's ugly
yeah
i think it's sort of both right it's uh
it's very solid black isn't really
struggling very much but it's also the
bishop on b7 is uh
uh killed off yeah what what yasser is
indicating on the screen perhaps the one
the one way i can think of improving
their position
yeah with white you kind of want to play
three perhaps bishop f1 queen e2 if you
could prevent the pawn from reaching the
b5 square
the pawn on e4 eventually could become
weak which is why i think black is very
incentivized to try to push for b6b5 as
early as possible if it works cool all
right and our final game that we haven't
looked at yet looks like
also a mess this is the
uh when we left it that was the pawn
sacrifice we talked about this
peter and more or less
you could have taken everything off if
you had wanted at this point you
how do you but then you're left with a
very passive position like if you take
on a fourth twice here right you you
deserve you preserved the pawn on c5 at
least for the time being but you left
with that really really stupid bishop on
g7 agreed let's not go there so yeah
richard chooses to try and equalize in a
much more kind of a diverse manner yeah
by playing
uh
c6 trying to provoke d6 and now trying
basically to trade the c6 pawn for the
d6 pawn okay
so if i take you're going to go back to
c7
and then i gotta have a nasty pin no i'm
in an sap queen a8 is on your ears 28 is
a problem i i don't think wind takes six
is a very serious try no you have to
choose between queen c3 and queen a3 i
mean the queen before c5 i think is
another way to make an immediate draw
right
uh yeah c5 knight c5 for k1 and then
queen takes d6
c5
oh you still go queen a8 i apologize i i
keep forgetting about this uh pin down
the uh
around the file so so peter uh say it
again what do you what do you reckon uh
white has as a way to avoid pc3 maybe
queen c3 okay you defend a1 yeah you
tickle but i guess okay i guess okay six
is just no okay it's between g3 right
and then queen a8 yeah maybe rook a6 is
just enough here
knight c4 though i haven't really
settled on uh on any kind of a knight c4
is nasty
that could actually uh the issue here
the issue for black here is that if you
make a draw here you make a draw but if
you don't make it immediately you
probably never knew yeah i mean if you
ever allowed a and let this pond live
that would be
a game game set
match
um yeah iii played by about by anton in
the meantime so yeah that's a very
clever move we will now see what what uh
richard thinks about the whole thing
yeah and again i'm with you 100 if you
don't make a draw in the next three
moves if you don't win the d6 or trade
it for something or trade it for
something
uh it will be really really bad for
black so
we'll keep an eye as richard looks like
he's going into the tank here because
this is a
very very critical
moment and uh over to you alejandro what
do the
probably the engines think it's just
fine daniels thinks black's better
because rook a7 in this position the one
move we didn't look at
i'm trying to i'm trying to understand
this okay give me a second uh well we're
just we're just going up to the g6 pawn
if i play rook a7 queen c5 is just a
drop but what rook d7 also exists there
right so i guess you start playing for a
win yeah
yeah black seems to be
threatening the d6 and queen a8 ideas
just about i
just
help me out here guys queen b4
against
rook a7 if you go rook d7 then i've got
knight c five and knight
i think group queen are gonna queen
eighteen with ninety six right okay um
that's a
that's a fork
so help me out and wait
wait wait what i kind of played rook d4
at the end i'm not playing for an
advantage but oh
i'm not playing for an advantage yeah
you can take on the eight and take off
yeah
first of all but i'm wondering i'm
wondering if i can just go rookie a
[ __ ] buffet here actually with the with
the white pieces where they are i'm
wondering if i have enough time okay
seven there you go richie playing the
most precise move
because
even though we we really like
white's position it visually optically
optically but the more you analyze it
the more you realize wait d6 needs to be
defended it is an important pawn can you
do it
this is one of those variations where if
you get away
with just capturing the pawn on d6 then
you're absolutely fine you're absolutely
fine yeah
nothing uh
bishop has done something quite striking
yeah he's going he's gone g5 without
even taking on f6 there
i'm so that if i play f5 you're going to
go g6
we're definitely going to check that
that's that smells of prep
oh my gosh that is so that's such a
pretty move oh come on oh come on you
got it come on you gotta like that
that's very nice actually it is very
cute wow
and it just completely it doesn't it
doesn't win a little bit it just it's
over like the game is immediately over
rogue one check even yeah yeah yeah yeah
richie won check
you can be ruthless yeah and now knight
g5 and yeah you can never go to e7
because because bishop bishop a3 remains
a problem oh yeah that's just you take
this and
take it
so that he doesn't go through a c7 yeah
to play for you oh my word oh g6 is just
a lovely shot and
yeah that means i have to play bishop e7
i know that the e5 square it also means
that taking on f6 is on
twice on f6 is on tap for white so
bishop e7 certainly looks like a logical
move problem
is that if you take i can just keep the
tension also with the move h4
uh and i think i like keeping the
tension with it because can i play f5 f5
h5 is still very dangerous because it's
a g6 system and you can't really move
anything right yeah
you're completely stuck you you you
never have any squares for any of your
pieces
this is a very nice concept by this i
really really like this i agree with you
and as we were coming on air for this uh
game you asked the question can vishy do
the incredible
6-0
at this moment i think uh dude has
fallen into some
heavy prep
yeah
and just to remind everybody where our
standings are
this year nan is
making a statement
wonderful people yeah it is it is
wonderful to watch and uh as usual when
he's playing well he is one of the most
exciting players in the world to watch
you know everything flows naturally
pieces pieces go where they belong and
he's also as we're watching right now he
is very very well booked up and
people underestimate just how good he is
opening prep was gary had this wonderful
ex
quip
that when uh aronian
is playing great the world's just a
better place yeah and it's sort of like
vichy too yeah yeah yeah there's she's
playing great it's just the world's a
better place and definitely more than
more than one person you can say that
about and visually very much belongs in
h
7h6 now wow that is really throwing down
the very provocative challenge do you
like that move uh peter
um i'm i'm slightly spoiled by the fact
that i saw the machine was suggesting it
oh
um i really should stop looking at
alejandro's scream but it's like your
mind is drawn to
to you know you know somewhere you know
there's there's an answer there and also
there's a hundred there so you
and he's such a
eye candy kind of
guy uh alejandro why does the machine
like h6 because of this detail that
after pawn takes f6 you have an
important move king takes f6 is actually
surprisingly okay i don't know how but
king takes f6 bishop f4 bishop g7 holds
what it doesn't it's not the best way of
playing but it holds but a better way of
playing i think a more human way of
doing this is to put the bishop on d6
first yeah absolutely so that when you
check which you kind of have to do i can
now take on f6 of course you don't take
on e5 and give me a protected pass pawn
there right you take on f6 and then
you're threatening to take on e5 so you
have to play bishop f4 and now you
defend i think rook t8 is a human move
you just defend the bishop against any
discoveries although the engine is
saying that you could also start moving
the rook to h7 and moving it to g7
getting some activity yourself obvious
compensation strong bishop strong bishop
strong knight i don't think that white's
pieces are worth less than blacks
but it's still an exchange and you will
eventually have to prove that your
position remains as good as blacks as
the rooks improve so compensation for
visually the edges are saying they're
typical zeros but a fascinating struggle
ahead h6 was an excellent move wow
wow that was really throwing down the
gauntlet and
i think dude has fallen into some really
great homework and defined h7h6 i mean
salute yeah it's it's so very very well
nicely played by
by the young pole uh in the meantime
yeah the
we should we should be watching this i
guess but uh things are developing on
other boards i think
just draw our attention to wesley so's
game for a second uh as he's up against
david when we left it we kind of like
wesley's position but somehow they
really
warmed up to wesley's position after the
rover rook up rook e3 and it just feels
like this knight on e5 versus this
passive bishop you put the pawn back on
e6 you give white an isolated pawn and
you know we've got all kinds of things
to discuss somehow the pawn on d5 and
the bishop on c6 don't make a good
impression on my eyes it's so it's a
very straightforward plan as well
because i think if you give black enough
time to somehow consolidate they will
they will there will not be enough for
for white to push but rookie 3 g3 is
surprisingly annoying because
yeah the pawn on h6 will will start
hanging straight away and how do you
even protect it like
you would like maybe to play something
like this buffet here on on general
grounds yeah but after rook g3
what is it what is even the response to
a very very straightforward idea of
bishop takes him unfortunately
yeah i don't like reaching for the g6
pawn either but i would like anything
else uh king h7 hangs the f7 uh pawn so
it's
surprisingly awkward
i don't know what that anything else is
honestly so yeah it's so it's a tricky
one for for for david to
is there any thing any i i'm i'm very
reluctant to allow queens it costs a
full pawn as well right even if you
don't get made enough to queen h5 which
you reach which you very much very much
could be yeah
even the very simple of you know
double double capture only four double
capture on c6
and then we go rookie three takes e4
it's not entirely equal even i i was
seriously considering it
because i don't like anything else but
yeah i'm not sure it equalizes and also
as you as you pointed out queen h5 could
might just be extremely very chilling
yeah uh so something for uh the young
uh romanian to ponder to ponder yeah
what do you have for us in the uh kings
india korobov updates here against
richard rapport because after the
precise move rook a7
korboff said okay i have to take the
pawn on c6 just so i'm not worse even if
i lose my pawn on d6 who cares but this
turned out to be surprisingly bad we
thought about bishop d7 turned
everything off on a4 let's make a draw
right richard was not interested in any
of that he played the excellent move
queen a8 you cannot take on eight
because rook that f takes a we have the
same problem down the a file no defense
on the rook on a1 you cannot move this
night it just gets picked up so the
queen has to retreat to c2 but here
comes the tempo rook c8 queen d1 and
rook c6 one of the good moves that white
had it blackout in this position just
trying to pick up the d6 spot in the
best case scenario and also why not rook
f to a6 not to mention that it
importantly stops the move knight b6 96
was a tempo move in many scenarios to
get out of the pins on the a file so
drook c6 excellent move korboff now
thinking 17 minutes for him to find ways
to play knight b3 seems to be the only
move the engines are saying it's not a
hugely decisive advantage for black but
knight is tough to find right rook takes
a seven look rook takes a four seven
decent but you got d7 and you're still
gonna be okay the engines don't think
that it's fully equal but even this is
pretty ugly because yeah it's not the
best bishop but it's this problem right
this problem on the a file and i think
the engines are advocating for this for
white just because you don't lose the
knight
wow but it barely holds and they don't
find anything better at this point
there's just nothing better that they
can see to do against such strong
threats like rook face rook ca6 rook
takes d6 even the move bishop fade is a
threat just bring the bishop that's not
participating in the game into the game
this rook is just stuck
it's stuck behind the queen the queen
can't move and the rook can't rejoin the
fray huge problems for the ukrainian
player richard might be going on a
hat-trick today as if he wins this game
it'll be three in a row for richard
rapport wow not bad at all fantastic in
fact um
maybe his king's indian isn't the most
precise but uh he's really making the
most out of this position absolutely
like what he's doing uh a game i'd like
to turn our attention to only because of
the visual effects is carol versus
levonaronian 16 pawns on the board and
you don't see this often
the five pawn attack is uh
he's winning the prop bet yeah yeah
i'm not entirely sure what the prop bet
was but he's winning it three you know
five pawns along the fourth rank uh we
we know about the four pawns attack we
now have to talk about the five pawns
attack
yeah um
less space i feel like black property
should still be fine uh i i do like
having having the bishops but i very
much like how
uh
cariel uh treated this position from the
moment that we uh we lost we left it on
night b6 yeah he took on b6 which is
obviously not something you dream of
doing and doubling the pawns but you do
have the space and i also very much like
this yeah very forthright idea of
pushing pushing g4 creating a threat of
knight five which the one felt obliged
to reply to with g76 i'm pretty sure he
was not dreaming of playing the 76 in
this position but allowing knight to
fight is arguably worse right so g6 is
now a very very clear-cut idea of
challenging for the center with all with
all you have with knight g2 rg8 f4
i tried figuring out if i like c65 here
it's kind of a strange move because
generally speaking we are creating this
huge hole on d5 for the knight on g2 to
get to but because there's a rook on d8
if you kind of naively re replied to c5
with g5 g5 thinking that you know the
9395 will follow i get my rook to g4
faster than you get your knight 35 which
i suspect will be uh good enough for
black like maybe just immediately before
and i'm going to leave it there if you
play bishop b2 right i'm not i'm not
moving it i'm i'm very much offering it
as a student of barbados yeah yeah
yeah yeah queen v6 queen c6 go ahead
take nine but but i think the bigger
issue is if you play if you play c5
there
i think white starts by playing maybe f
takes e5 or maybe the immediate d5
uh and
yes you have solved like there is now no
normal pressure on your center as such
but your bishop on f7 your bishop on f7
is very very stuck yeah the bishop on a3
will be on b2
heavily discouraging any kind of an
opening in the center rook f1 double or
you know triple on the f file and
you know
probably okay white is having all the
fun yeah yeah it's you're defending on
the back foot the rest of the game yeah
it's uh it's just very difficult to
imagine how you how you enjoy this with
black
lavon goes with b6 b5 which is a
different way of challenging for uh
for space and maybe
one day hoping to shut down even so i
kind of thought that this bishop on a3
you know was going to go to b2
essentially okay
you you tricked me you tricked me you
you
you forced yeah something like this is
playable even even still the d45 in the
composition is probably not a huge
mistake either because i mean those are
why for white yeah
without cbcb maybe even without even
opening the c5 i don't know which like
which of the ways the pawn get bonds get
traded here i prefer it's funny that all
of the pawns see there seems to be a
great deal of tension between the pawns
but in truth
the 60 pounds on the port it's really
locked down you know it's crazy uh
nice position and uh b5 and for hero
maybe this is his best
chance of scoring well yeah but uh
coming back to what uh christian told us
uh about his conversation with with the
youngsters yeah
yeah he's he's once again down 10
minutes on the clock in a in a
complicated position perhaps not as
complicated as some of the ones he's had
early in the tournament but still this
is not a very straightforward position
to play considering you know how many
different things you can do with the
structure in the center so you have to
weigh
all of these things up
uh and he's playing as somebody who will
be you know extremely capable of
exploiting the slightest
you don't want to go down to you know
too much on the clock against somebody
like liv what is the clock situation
seven against 16 i think on my screen oh
that's a that's a big edge okay we'll
keep an eye on that one i did want to go
back to our vichy a non-game if again
just for the fact that we were
witnessing something incredible uh vishy
for those of you who are joining us late
first of all shame on you second of all
five in a row five in a row and yeah and
playing a very very uh ambitious line in
this game where he basically gave up
gave up the exchange by move ten or
thereabouts and he's playing for sort of
purely positional compensation here and
look at that move space iii i'm
i would like to go fe5 and kind of
settle the structure here okay go ahead
let's take stakes i'm not sure i should
be even yeah
maybe
okay just a second i do have this nasty
nasty move
that is very strong bishop e2 to h5 i do
have h6
i do i mean i probably still play rog
597
oh oh which page five i will take
i will play king g6 i will put the
knight on the f5 and i will claim that i
have compensation i probably do have
compensation which is fair which is fair
perfect you know what i was thinking i
get my bishop on age five you got yours
and you will never
ever move again okay uh
marvelous
imbalanced position
bishop a3 is not the first move that
comes to your mind i think well he wants
to stop 97 i think yeah but a lot of us
were we were focused on more or less i
think on this one no i think you have to
stop knights i think 97 is such an
integral part of how black comes out of
the corner that any move that allows
postpones it postpones it for a move is
very very
high on the list bishop a3 and
again i mean black is in a box
if he doesn't
uh bite now
with captures i'm not sure
i have a better suggestion i mean the
problem is i thought if i took peter
exactly yeah i was planning to go bish
buffet here exactly uh and and asking
the question whether you want to trade
those uh or not there's there's
compensation even if you trade like you
can take on a fade play 94.
and i was going to take with the ruckus
yeah 94 97 is seemingly quite bad
yeah so yeah
you have to cover against this threat
you maybe you maybe you have time enough
to play king e7 rook f7 or h5 rook h6 as
you're indicating
but i mean even sort of long-term
positional compensation here i go f2 f4
exactly it's not and um
yeah i'm not sure white is doing yeah
but
now you can actually do this yeah i'm
seven h6 i'm just in time but even
i'm still i feel
boy okay we do uh have the movie five
played five i'm very curious how how
vishy is planning to respond to this i i
feel like it's one of those positions
peter
i know i'm about to be handcuffed and if
i get handcuffed i can just you know
i've been arrested that's it it's game
over but if i can avoid uh you know
being really tied up
it's an exchange it is still it's still
a full exchange there for black that's a
fascinating game we'll keep an eye on
that one absolutely again the lavonna
rooney and game let's see what we did
against b5 i think cyril he played what
he was suggesting is cbcb and bishop c2
the queen came out d5 creamy 6 king h1
um
i think blick is fine i think although
you kind of need not the g4 g5 is
worrying me i was about exactly
i was about to say the structure is very
solid and then i realized we have to pay
attention to the ideas of g4 g5 g4 g5
might just actually be but levon is
allowing it because i think one also
wants the the structure to blow up i
think he very much welcomes
let's see it i mean i'm looking and i'm
seeing a queen g3 in the very near
future keeping in mind that rook c2 is
an issue
but queen g3 might just blow up black's
position after the move g5
whoa i'm not sure i'm not sure how i
want to uh how i want to mean this i was
wondering if i can just pass but
then king g8
for instance king g8 just sidestepping
the let's put a reasonable move on the
board the last thing you ever want to do
is capture here and allow gf
okay
uh
but i'm not sure i'm not sure i am happy
with any of this like take on f6 take on
e5 okay that looks like uh
let's go right kirill goes with rook f1
without you
but i think he he probably feels that
it's not really going away right
because black isn't playing g6 g5
themselves it gives up the f5 square for
the knight on e3 so it's difficult to
stop
i don't mind the idea of postponing it
for a move because i don't it doesn't
look like black has very much to do you
you useful move and good c5 c2 maybe
yeah stopping f2 is not nothing yeah
exactly that's uh useful and again i'm
looking at this bishop on f7
peter and i'm saying you got to play b5
b4 bishop e8 bishop b5 you've got three
you need three moves to ever bring that
piece into an active square
and i don't know but i it feels
it looks visually very good for white i
don't know it's very pleasing yeah
and uh
alejandro you got our favorite uh
interview anton
uh
position yeah but his position is not
very good if look at what happened he
did find knight b3 after a long thing so
kudos to him to keep the game alive and
still manageable after rook takes a4 the
just thought bishop takes b3 and then
rook takes d6 was more precise it gets
kind of the same position
uh in which black picks up the spawn on
e4 by a tactical sequence of course
after d7 you kind of have to take the
spawn there's no real choice and we land
into this position in which black is
currently up a pawn but the knight as
long as it returns to the defense four
against three you have very realistic
chances of holding the correct move in
this position just start bringing your
pieces back knight d2 as played in the
game the queen has to go somewhere where
defensive rook on c6 probably c2 is
gonna be chosen and again four versus
three no clear way to simplify this
position into a draw for anton he's
gonna be suffering for a while quincy
two already on the board as we see
richard gunning for his third victory in
a row today he will need to destroy this
defense of anton and it will be a stiff
defense because four versus three is
theoretically a draw in most end games
which allows white to exchange pieces in
many positions now which ones you want
to exchange first that's complicated i
think that if you get the rooks off
that's probably the easiest way uh yeah
that probably is ideal yeah ideal for
white is to take the rooks off but four
versus three even if you get the minor
pieces off that should be comfortable
still
those exchanges have not happened and
black is more active
richard came
on
on the show today i had an interview
with christian where he said well 50
you know he had to this draw two draws
and a win yesterday and
was sort of like okay rapid chess rapid
chess you know anything can happen but
if he were to go three and oh boy that
puts a lot of wins in his sails again
he's going to go to madrid next month
play to try to become
challenger of the world champion magnus
carlson so he would love a good result
here people yeah in the meantime in the
two games we were talking about
previously both kind of proceeded along
the expected path we actually got all
the way to 94 h5 in the vichy versus do
the game uh we had that on the board
yeah
previously yeah white still optically
has decent compensation but black is a
couple of moves away if you get to play
97 and then put the rook on g8 and put
another one on h6 perhaps everything is
covered
everything is covered and you start at
some point counting you know how many
how many rooks you have on the board
you're pleased you know
yeah and and once you start making quiet
moves like
this is an indication okay
although
maybe he is creating a no no this is
clever
97 i want to go bishop d7 yes i go h6
and i want to remind you there is also
the queen side on the board right rugby
one i think that's a very d and the idea
is that with your king here this rook is
kind of passive we also opened up the
first rank for two for the narrow b6
yeah and i i've gotten to the weaknesses
you certainly have
uh at this point i'm probably going to
go knight c6 or i i'm going to do
something to try to
release that i like matches six yeah
to to relieve the pressure
um i think match six is correct but why
it shouldn't be worse at all there i
think white is fine at the very least
too um 97 isn't forced you can start
with maybe rook h6 but
yeah okay start to find a better move
for black after bishop d7 than 97 well
the reason that we might want to start
with rook h6 is maybe bishop d7 maybe we
we
bishop v6 rogue g7
i wanted that with the rook on the face
but it wasn't working but it's working
it's working now
if it was a puzzle rush you'd see it
instantly but it wasn't he still saw it
yeah
it wasn't but that's that was pretty
yeah it is
i was i was trying to make that work for
for the last i don't know how long it
wasn't working with the rook on the face
yeah because this exists after bishop d7
what do you play like rook h6 bishop d7
how do you avoid
knight e7
yeah what what is your other move yeah
it looks like you kind of have to right
everything seems worse ruby one is still
a threat so you might as well just
develop a piece right it's not like rook
g6 i'll take on g6 and calculate that
out i'll just play rugby one anyway
exactly yeah even though i'm not sure
that under six is bad no no i don't
think about that yes yeah so let's
remark maybe we're headed towards that
position 97 would be one and i very much
like your knight c6 because you do need
to limit the amount of pieces on the
board like you
well all of white's pieces are optimized
whereas blacks needs you know black
needs to throw in h4 and rook h5 and
rookman
the shocking thing for me is the zeros
after specifically rook beat or b6
knight g6
rook b8 sorry i'm sorry what should i do
yeah well you have to defend v7 this one
you cannot give up so rook
yeah rook b8 rook b6 yeah
and 96 apparently and knight g6
triple zeros triple zeros
life is
unfair
and then you die
uh
why
if i'm sagging because because the king
is only two and there's a lot of jumps
like you take only six was checked go
king goes to f8 and then suddenly you
realize that
e5 is hanging neither for check is also
a very serious threat and you you can't
deal with all of it properly so black
actually develops some counterplay but
yeah finding this over the board yeah i
don't know wow
difficult
wow okay uh we'll definitely keep an eye
on that game i will let's go to wesley
we haven't seen wesley in a while
uh yeah i'm very good we did see the 94
sorry i very much like how uh david is
defending here he's gone bishop to six
and then king of faith the move that i
think is very easy to miss as an idea in
general getting on your sneakers and
getting ready to run for the hills
and now yeah the pieces have come out
bishop d2 is a clever move here by the
way looking like it's abandoning the
node upon e5 but the bishop will come to
c3 or b4 i was wondering if the proper
way to respond here is just to take on
e5 and play queen f5 and put the rook on
e6 and claim that you know nobody is
better because it's just completely
symmetrical but i guess maybe white is
sort of faster you can play bishop c3
here kind of inviting rook e6 i can
plant the bishop on d6
i like the rook there that was my point
i think the bishop i know the rook is
going to go on east ah okay yeah
and i think if you play bishop before
bishop v6 you kind of abandon any hope
of advantage because it really does
nothing at all there i want it on c3 and
i want a rook on d6 like bishop city
rookie 6 rook d1 okay and then
eventually i want to plonk it on 6 and
claim that i have something i'm not sure
i have anything on it
what are you guys looking at gabriel
let's go play g5
okay like a boss
look at that look at that move
why like a boss
whoa that that's a feisty move the idea
of course the rook on g4
it's kind of trapped right i'm a few
moves six is a huge threat f6 is a huge
big threat the knight on e5 is trapped
queen e6 f5 f4 is not such a lousy
threat either actually and i understand
that you guys were trying to equalize
this for black but that's only because
you read the names wesley playing that's
good
when you realize you take the names away
just look at the position black has a
pair of bishops the rook's stuck on g4
and you just have actual serious
tactical problems as white it's not
white that's playing for a win here guys
wow
no you're right we were under the uh
i mean huge credit has to go to uh to
gabriel for support
watching the fact that he should be
playing for a win here yeah right
no that was
frankly that was hidden i i
that that was
i didn't see that coming that that that
that's a cold shower uh can i just look
at some cr oh you're you're defending f1
i was looking at 400 things yeah well i
was hoping
i was hoping that you know
i got some some some nasties
unfortunately effie also doesn't have a
threat because you're not threatening
he takes d6 right
i i invoking g8 like a vfe king g8 is
probably even more efficient right
and just just looking cheated yeah
right yeah and you just sidestep all of
those threats
yeah i was playing rook f1 and h4 rick
g4 none of this comes with any any oomph
uh i take it all back
um wesley
oh yeah where's this steel he's still
doing well on the clock but that's about
the only thing you can say you can say
for his position
maybe the good news is like even though
the knights trap maybe the bishops trap
could i play like a4 and force the
bishop to go to some square that i can
capture it i mean right now yeah um
a4 immediately yeah just so that i can
like you don't lose a piece i think i
think we go bishop c6 and the issue is
like if you take take you're you you
you're now stuck with this horrible no i
think with the with the rook why would
they go of course of course of course
yeah
yeah struck on g4 is really
not
very beautiful
it's just dead this rook is just dead
yeah the queen is moving by what is this
wait a minute hold on but i'm trying to
avoid reciting bishop f4
i do have queen a3 check
and i can throw in rook c2 to start
right i can i can be maybe slightly
clever about things that is a unless i
blundered f3 i did if i did blunder f3 i
don't know if it's strong or not
dang
keeping it going peter nice somehow
uh there's also a slightly large like if
we go back for a second like the
previous move like i can go for instance
perhaps
yeah you want to play bishop c3 my point
was if i play rookie six here yeah
sort of putting it on a protected square
to blunt f3 you you're not actually
threatening to take because rook c2 in
the end just gives me a large no it
doesn't no it doesn't like you have
bishop
right okay i need to stop rambling
we need to we need to wait for wesley to
make a move and a good move at that and
wesley's clock is peter
uh five against three and a three and a
half yeah okay but wesley has just
this move g5 has just stopped
the american grand master and said whoa
he didn't see that coming i don't think
i don't think he he expected this i
think he expected as sort of we did he
expected a fight
offensive
reaction his gun queen e3 g3 which
which wow
that's what shouldn't be good yeah
mean e3 g3
bishop oh he's got knight g6 yeah he is
defending against f6 by by creating
toxic yeah yeah f6 knight g6 because g6
is not a threat of it no right and and
this i think should give you an idea
that rookie six is like the first thing
you look at in this position is probably
rookie six just to protect the bishop on
d6 that's like a great start and now f6
is back being uh being a very strong
threat back in the movie on a front
burner but here's if white's busted
come on i'm reaching into the mind of
wesley wesley is looking at a mate on g7
something or yeah this is this
against three minutes this is not it
probably loses against machines but
against three minutes in a practical
game you want something cleaner for
black i'm pretty sure you want something
cleaner okay
but rookie six i believe
i'm wondering if h4 rook takes e5 isn't
just winning for black oh no you're
telling me my rook on g4 is like can i
go rookie 5g bishop b5
rook i'm wondering if you can go f6 hg
just hg right yeah that as well yeah but
then i was going to sacrifice a bishop
and absolutely they're not your things
anyway right just give them away give
them away
look one of the great parts about being
a chess commentator is you can look like
a tactical genius absolutely and they
remember when it works and when it fails
it's just like okay let's go do it but
you know it's such a bad habit because
i've been playing tournaments where i'm
thinking oh what if i just sack a piece
it's actually my piece i'm actually
giving it away i can't do that
and david he had little time and he
chose a practical decision which also
very much exists in the position i don't
hate it you i don't hate it either he's
better he's better queens will need to
come off because of how horrible the
rook on g4 is i'm pretty sure he took
twice honestly he just took twice yeah
yeah and it's it's
83 yeah queen b3 exists sadly i thought
movie 3 was worse than it is it's
actually playable
because the end games once again wesley
wants to
maintain the illusion that black could
be
under threat so i think in order to
maintain that illusion
so that's where you think queen b3 but
alejandro over to you as we
we kind of got mesmerized there it does
not matter how we got here we got here
right none of them
they're all dead but it's okay none of
the kingpins are not alive either
somehow we got here it's a huge mess
both kings under attack not anymore it's
just a draw now now it's just a draw
because they're gonna have wait how does
this a draw the queen there's a
perpetual okay
seven queen h4
why am i taking the perpetual as white i
go queen e6 king g7
queen d7
oh you can just go this way yeah and i
lose
now you don't have queen h4 check if you
had gone 27 check
you
but i thought you were about to suggest
after king h6 continue right here yeah
yeah king queen d7 king h6 and if i take
on c8 i guess i oh rook f4 is just
looking forward looking forward it's
easy enough because you're also getting
mated with rookies you don't need to be
yeah i don't have to be too much if yeah
yeah so bishop f1 is a draw but there's
other ideas the move rook f8 also exists
is pretty cool the idea is that knight
takes h3 can be met with rook takes f1
and you're giving yourself some hope of
defending wow on the seven so it's not
completely over there are some chances
here for both sides crazy it should end
up drawing some kind of crazy perpetual
right but it's not over quite yet and
what have we said about chefchenko's
rapid chest he burns
all his time yeah all of it 25 seconds
left against seven minutes and 20. so
levon for sure will find something
tricky clever keep the game going if if
he can find anything here that continues
the game he plays it instantly yes i
mean he against 25 seconds you're very
very interested in the idea of
continuing the game this is a fantastic
position i hate to say it
that the anton game anton's a piece down
but uh
i studied this ending and the crazy part
is it's a draw
it's not it is yeah i was wondering i
was wondering you're pieced down but
somehow
it's the wrong it's a wrong pawn but
this does not surprise me because if you
take off f h it's actually not that
trivial even it's not it's winning yeah
it's winning it's winning but i've seen
people get to that position and then
realize
it's not that easy right like you win it
eventually you go around and around and
you win you realize you have to make the
king not promote your pawn
but talk again about the game of uh
lavon for a moment because that is just
one of the most chaotic looking
positions after knight g2 to f4 that
i've seen
how would the game continue after rook
f8 it's just rook fade is a cool move
let's go into this position let's work
our fade and you have a couple of
choices taking is okay you can take on
f2 take on f2 and then take on h3
because
you have a perpetual
uh as white as well as black here it's
crazy right you have to go up
track is okay for why taking on d1
allows the immediate queen e6 and
despite the fact that the rook is on f8
it doesn't really help that much against
the perpetual's queen e6 and because you
always have a diagonal check as well as
a seventh ranked check or an eighth rank
check you will make a draw and if you go
the other way then uh if you go like
rook f3 in this position the king
surprisingly on h4 is now being harassed
and again queen d1 queen eight is or 26
is going to be a draw instead the game
continued with different directions
different reactor bishop g4 player
attacking this rook on d1 check
immediately king g7 played already and
knight e6 check on the board no choices
for lavon he goes to h6 queen g5 is made
go to eight shade queen e5 is made king
g8
knight d4
cuts the queen from the defense of this
rook on f2 also dies so he must take on
e6 queen takes e6 played already you
don't have any real threats on the
second round just yet and well white is
kind of crudely taking on c8 yes or
playing czech and d7 so you still have
to be careful as black in this position
still double-edged i think rook cf8 is
logical but at that point of course
white can
switch to giving checks whenever he
feels like it shabchecko should have the
draw in his hand
it's the question how much lavon wants
to keep trying
right because the more he avoids the
perpetuals the more risky it gets right
here's the past pawn on d6 right i mean
you could just lose if you don't deliver
mate trying desperately to win
uh that's a
that's a crazy case yeah i love it i'm
enjoying it
everything about this yeah this is a lot
of fun and here's yeah he's down to 27
seconds which is uh
uh you know by his standards a lot of
time i would suggest
but yeah not a particularly fun position
to play uh
with white because you actually run out
of checks but 100 is not entirely true
after rook cfa because after queen e5
check we can put the king on h6 and with
the rook on f2 there is no check from h2
so you don't actually have a follow-up
with a check i think the problem was uh
uh
that plays for a loss right
i'm not sure why if one is hanging i'm
not yeah but if i take on f2 your rook
of seven queenie five here right queen
queenie five first queen e5 first i i
like queen of five first sure i
understand rook f2 king h6 i think was
peter's idea and i take on f2
i and i have to take with the rules you
have to take with the rook if you think
with the queen queen h2 trade squeeze
and i
you're not on time yeah i'm not you're
not on time with the king
anything like queen g3 or even d7
immediately
yeah and
yeah d7 queen e3 i was kind of hopeful
but maybe i'm a bit over optimistic well
i mean i i i can see i can spot him yeah
so i guess we go to ng3 actually not not
disappointing
but after queen g3 yeah i mean i'm
probably playing playing you start yeah
you start wondering
right yeah
a little bit yeah all right well we'll
keep an eye on that one i want to go
back to the vichy game just because it's
so important for our standings and what
a game it is wow
and vichy again i mean it's all about
this incredibly
difficult
positional pressure that
king before is such a cool move that is
i know cool that is it's a visual it's a
it's like kappa blanca yeah yeah just
just go in with the king towards b6 and
then give me six
kappa is happy about this one wow
king d4
that's a god come on come on
[Laughter]
come on check yeah king c5 uh check king
b6
okay uh
i know you've got bishop a6 i know you
don't have bishop a6 can you be seven so
what can i mean i should take on c3 yeah
let's
i mean
white has the draw here rook a7 is a
draw
very very easy
to try
but i don't think we have more as well i
don't see it either i'm going to go king
d8 and i was trying to sidestep rook a8
shaq i mean i can at the very least go
rogue yeah you said when there's a drone
that's the draw he mentioned yeah
and i don't see anything better right
right
king d4
well it's a very very cute concept you
know it's sad in chess you get one point
for the win and a half a point for the
draw and if this game ends up at a draw
you want to give vichy like three
quarters of a point for the creative
effort right that was amazing i was like
no dude defended magnificently he did
yeah he did but
draw as a drop
you you do feel that
you know the the the organizers of why
kansai had it sort of had the right idea
with the public prize yeah with the like
game of the day public prize oh yeah
yeah you you don't really want to give
points to people but you do want to
reward them reward reward people for
creating something that is so enjoyable
to watch and yeah this clearly wins game
game of the round
probably game of the day another game of
the round right despite a very likely
ending in a draw and there will be very
very many decisive games
dude i didn't play roxy fought check he
played rook 8 d7
rook
eight af7 yeah f7 rook d6 clearly white
cannot afford to trade at all
rook d6 is box yeah rook to six
and that's an improvement i mean rook
takes chat actually took me a while i i
never even considered what it was and
and and now that they use this again uh
i wonder how many people watching us
understand what you mean by box
box box because i i i i i
have a handshake yeah this ended in a
draw with the perpetual that we were
talking about you go to age six i think
you're losing so queenie six queen e5
finish the game
yes lavon and again we're back with
i think and this is just
after captures the rook went after the
c3 pawn
and vishy captured on e6 and we got
king to d6 look at this yeah not
capturing
i'm sure i like how this is going
although he has a very strong passer on
the e5 now he wants to hear checking e67
and so on right yeah bishop
and i don't know if
uh
clock clock clock d4
how much time did he have when he might
be four seconds four seconds yeah yeah
d4 yeah we can go rookie rookie 86 so we
can go
but he's done it yeah the e pawn seems
to be stronger than the the g pawn here
it's just running faster
uh yeah this is going to be very very
tricky for young shirts to handle
because with almost no time almost no
time and i think it just plays plays
easier for white than it plays for black
rook
rook c7
rook c7 so after the move e7 and he's
reaching three i guess is the idea
and then i'll move my
rookie three
where what oh i apologize uh you you
you've you've kept the e pawn under
yeah under control
and rookie it's still very very
confusing i don't think we're playing uh
yes
i think that's a very strong threat
oh yeah do you have three three
three seven d2 rook be a check or
something or is this a draw
what i have a perpetual right no he's
gone king if whoa
he's running he's running some risks
some risks here but maybe not very many
the king goes to f6 and he wants to pick
up the pawn on d3 and then queen the
queen the opponent who could blame him
i like that d2
so you've got a rook check coming to e3
more passers
d7 bishop d7 alejandro
bishop dc i like bishop d7 because she's
written
the point
wow roberto as well yeah okay rook
between start with
is also pretty pretty interesting yeah
yeah
i think he's reaching for that because
rigby ii
practically you have so many discoveries
again the clock time speed yeah
55 seconds against 28. yes 55 28.
oh my goodness rook b2 what a test yes
or do that
rook cg7
cg7 and if i go
bishop
c4 you go what a file i guess
it
has to be the a file otherwise you get
mated on the back ring so yeah you
choose a square for the bishop here
anything you do will force the king over
to the a file i very much like rook g7
though because we've put the rooks away
from you know getting blocked out by the
bishop so we're controlling
rookies
what
uh that throw that through that is
illegal uh
no discovered checks okay we can take
and go king b6 and this is a draw
because it's clear seven rook takes his
seven and then he comes to before and
yes he's got at least a draw yeah so
yeah
if youngster doesn't lose his mind here
black has a very comfortable draw with
him and he's he can even start with h3
right doesn't spoil anything he'll use
the h pawn as a d
yeah h3 well is king c8 winning
what king c87 no he ra
h5 what happens on e7 here
you're taking king c6 yeah yeah
oh yeah no no yeah you're taking king c6
it is
yeah and uh in the meantime that end
game that alejandra alluded to is now
and yeah somehow uh anton corbett lost
both of his f and h pawn in like
within the space of ten moves which
means that richard should win
uh
and a draw agreed even though they're
not supposed to agree to a draw they
should play it out
to once again
yes and we'll switch over very happy
that nobody nobody you know bugs them
about it by the way again we've lost
connections with is the fabi versus
radical which will be a draw which will
be a draw which will be wesley so
he's going to make a draw against
gabrieles who didn't actually have too
much trouble defending that one this one
ended in a draw so let's focus i guess
on richard can richie go three you know
and the answer should be absolutely yes
yeah this one is uh well it says made on
18 but this is the one i was talking
about i hate this endgame because the
engines are made in whatever but it's uh
sometimes not trivial
yeah wondering
okay you know i was he's not going for
some rook trade like what yeah i thought
maybe there was some way to keep the
king away from the corner but not just
yet no the way you win this is you get
the pawn to h3 and then you set up the
set uh the position with the rook on it
in the bishop on e3 and you give them
eight but you kind of need to know that
this is the way you win them and then
you have to avoid a couple stalemates
yeah because once a bishop gets to e3
there's definitely some chicks there and
yeah i watched during the the world cup
in in sochi there was a game being
played i think between uh katherine
laguna was playing this position against
somebody she did eventually win but uh
in rapid time controls it's very easy to
get somewhat confused i think definitely
i don't know why i've seen this position
like many times and every time it's yeah
it's kind of weird but every time it's
the same story they get to this position
black makes a ton of random moves
because they don't know how to make
progress they can't believe they're not
just winning they can't claim victory
yeah they can't claim victory right and
eventually they land on the one thing
they haven't tried which is the bishop
on e3 on the phone and hd that's the
only
actually the only thing that wins but
it's actually the only reason yeah if
you don't know and i i'm not entirely
sure why i know perhaps i have watched
somebody do it and i kind of clicked
around to figure out exactly how but
yeah
knowing knowing what wins you get there
reasonably comfortably i do know that
you need to stop the stale matrix
yeah wesley has drawn the game so that
means four draws that's all right so he
blundered his rook so it made things a
lot easier he blundered his rook
yeah
wow and for richard that's uh great news
as he's made it three in a row
why do people under his rook what well
he didn't blunder his rook but you have
to keep the king in the corner if you
want to have any chance of drawing uh
and if you've got king h1 rook h2 picks
up the gotcha
yeah two then the age of queensland
obviously exactly
so that starts happening so maybe rook f
well
how he maybe he should have just gone
king to h1 i mean he shouldn't bring the
rook to it doesn't matter the end game
is lost i mean we okay we're wasting
much time fair fair
vishy
still is remarkable
king fishy not six out of six but five
and a half we'll give him a pass on that
one i mean 11 out of 12. geez what a way
to start the tournament here i think
he's finished grand chess tours with
less than 11 points total and now he's
on 11 out of six rounds he's he's just
on fire here right and i love the way
he's playing chess putting the pressure
on dude until the very end that was that
was fun at the end of the game who was
playing for a win
like what both guys here because the
polish player you know he had his face
he had his passport he looks quite
active at some point vision did have to
make a couple of only moves i thought it
was a fun fun fun game oh yeah oh yeah i
mean and i i i'm with you 100 on the
public prize and what we're talking
about is from the very opening this he
made a very enterprising exchange
sacrifice which is rather
with this move g4
and he just kept the pressure yeah i
mean it was clearly clearly the concept
was something he knew of or perhaps he
didn't prepare it specifically for this
tournament but since he's actually
you know very seriously clearly playing
the the advance against the french here
at every opportunity maybe it is a part
of what he thought of uh as a part of
the repertoire for the tournament since
the field does feature a number of
people who can play the the the french
against you yep uh but yeah just he
plays very very fresh chess he plays
you know very close to
uh to do to what i like picture as you
know prime vichy right it's just such a
joy to watch his he's nice very very and
here's our current standings after two
game two days of play yeah two people
kind of separating themselves from the
field uh richard upward one every single
game today bravo yeah very well well
done very nice games as well and vishy
uh doing a half out of three here as you
see on your screen vishy uh only
dropping uh one draw uh in five games
allowing one draw against him uh leading
the field by by two points and richie
two points further
above everybody else
wesley may be leaving something on the
table uh with that the draw with levon
in the first round of the day possibly
yeah
do that sorry yeah and dude having a
kind of a topsy-turvy day starting with
the wind and losing uh that game to
wesley and
and we have an interview uh from warsaw
uh christian is with kirill srichenko
thank you uh peter we are here indeed
with kirill chefchenko kiril welcome to
the show welcome to the granchester what
does it mean this opportunity for you to
play against the best chess players in
the world
well first of all i would like to say
a huge thank you to everyone who
made this crunch store possible and for
opportunity to me to give this wild card
to play here i'm the
i'm very excited to play against uh
those all grandmasters and i
can see that
i can see their strength and try to do
my best but
uh of course it's
i had no before that experience to meet
very very top grandmasters but now i
have it so
i'm very happy to be here
and
yeah try to show exciting games how
would you say you live the first couple
of days emotionally uh how did you feel
these players
well i think uh
it's quite
unusual because for example i never seen
wesley saw in real life
and so it was very
fine finally i saw them all together
and of course it's very nice to
to
always analyze with them
games and
i'm very happy that
they are very kind to me and we are
discussing many different things and
i will
try to
do my best to
get into the store next time
yesterday we met uh at the restaurant
and you told me that in the first day
you felt you played a bit too aggressive
yes how did you change your strategy
going into the second day
well as you can see against anand i
didn't do that and
actually after that loose i decided okay
i will not play
too straight forward and
somehow i have to be more calm and
but today uh last game against levon
let's talk about that in fact let's uh
look at the last game against level take
us through the critical gate critical
points in the game
well he chose uh i played the royal
opposite with knight c3
he choose the kerosene variation with d6
and id7 it's quite
dubious by computer but
it's it seems very
solid because
he has
very solid structure and so
we
played some moves
and probably that was the
moment uh well as you see in the game i
give him chance to play knight b6 and
his pawn on e5 is very good safe yeah
yes very safe but maybe knight a4 was a
bit better because uh he he cannot play
knight b6 no there's no
c4 yeah and i can play s4 or
either was c4 is also very interesting
because here knight b6 i can just go
back knight c3 and already pawn is
straight to the knight
so yeah knight b6 and here i realized my
position is kind of worse knight b6 you
take b6 c4 here probably i was
curious about he could play b5 it's very
no no no no not this
maybe here yeah queen d3 here b5 is very
interesting move was i know there is
rook under attack some
i guess i mean uh he played king h8 and
bishop g4 he could play also rook a7
it's very interesting move because
now he's writing b5 and then so how b4
c5 is very
uh
he could try to close position to get
pair of bishops advantage here when he
played kicking a j through one bishop g4
and i thought my position is totally
worse but after
i played knight h4 g6 knight g2 i
started to think my position is not so
bad because his special bishops are very
passive and after rook d8 f4
uh position becomes very unclear because
like you you see again i go all in but
now now it's
it's might be paid for it because
there's a bit less species yeah you can
see bishops are stuck yeah and levon
told me after the games he was also
very surprised that this position is
very good for me but somehow in my
position if he goes c5 i go d5 and uh
now already my you have some
transmission i get g5 and if you close
g5 i just take knight e3 and i have no
risk so he played b5 here is also
interesting moment i thought about
bishop b2 probably was interesting but
here he can uh open
much more line files and uh
probably yeah that was that was maybe
interesting alternative but i took on b5
bishop two queen c6
d5 is also interesting
well can it get stalking h1 was
interesting alternative to d5 because
after d5 queen b6 king h1
looks at rook f1 bishop eight and he can
hear his ideas just play b4 bishop b5
now i decided okay i have to how do you
feel about your position now are you
confident i felt like uh if i go
uh if i play with
with very aggressive move i shouldn't be
worse but
of course in such position you can be
outplayed because
my king is just too weak but his kick is
also not so
very well defended also another point of
concern for us here in the studio as
well as for the guys in st louis was
that he had 12 minutes while you only
had three minutes were you concerned
about the time situation at all yeah i
wasn't
very confident at this point to
calculate some very long variations
because
i wasn't even sure that my position is
better because
well you can see bishop d7 is much
stronger than knight of g2 and if he
even this point uh lemon told me
i could play f5 but here i thought queen
d8 f take g6 king h8 and this position
looks uh
very interesting because i have paul now
but
his g file is open and uh rook c2 is
coming and probably jade's comment if i
take on h7 he can play queen sm or
otherwise rook c2 and position is very
complicated that's why i decided to just
uh take everything on e5 bishop h3 d6 i
was confident that i am not worse in
this position because my king is not
very weak at all but pawn d6 can create
some stress so i calculated some
small variations like rook fe-8 and
queen f4 probably and the idea if queen
b7 just d7 is winning nice yeah
so yeah rook f2 is very nice move
and here i i've found out yeah i can
give perpetual check yeah queen d5 queen
of queen e5 but i decided to play knight
for it
was
like uh last week i i saw rookie fade
move but here i probably
was too confident that i can find
something but computer shows i don't
have anything perhaps there's always
some sort of perpetual yeah if you think
yeah yeah exactly h3 and then check
check check exactly so he played bishop
g4 queen z5 king g7 knight e6
takes on e6 and here probably that was
like the only chance uh i saw to take on
f2 queen f2 queen d4 but i found this
position is
totally draw because rook d5 rogue b8 or
even b4 king and sacrifice the ball
rookie fighting e6 my king is completely
stuck on king's side
and he can just push his pawns and
it's not very clear who plays for me
absolutely so that was very he wanted to
avoid this yeah because
yeah i didn't see it all because if he
if he tries to uh refuse the draw he
plays this i will take take a queen h2
and his king is not in time to block
this pawn so very interesting game where
it ends and i am very satisfied that
this it was very
um
goodbye computer agents revelation a
solid performance uh today how would you
assess
your overall performance up to this
point
well i still have
some
blunders and some points like with
vishan i blunted long castle and was i
was very curious how could i blunder
this but after that i tried to get some
counter play but it was impossible
because he defended very well and very
precise
but
yeah i will try to change something but
the last game against levon showed that
not everything is bad yeah
always entertaining chess always a
fighter we're looking forward to see
your games in the next few days thanks
very much guys back to you thank you
christian thank you carol i like the
fact that carol says okay
i'm gonna
draw back
and then he goes all in
i mean it's just great and here's our
standings after day two uh peter yeah as
you can see uh vishek currently just uh
crushing crushing the field wow two
points ahead of uh richard rapport who
is further two points ahead of uh every
everybody else yeah wesley wesley and
young system uh tied for third uh fabian
levon ties the fifth uh one more day of
rapid in front of us still plenty of
action and then non-stop action on
uh
monday when we will have nine rounds of
blitz both days and playoffs if
necessary
absolutely uh going on there
um predictions uh how are we doing um
who got vishy
of silence
silence in the studio silence in poland
but good
let vishy come here and silence us with
his good chest and show us that our
predictions are not that great well not
that great i'm in second place right now
so
i'm in third
not doing so badly
not doing so badly there yeah i like i
like my do that pic
yeah what say what second place are you
mistaken
rickard and duda they're tied for second
place right no no what no
no
sorry third time for third time for
thirty eight yeah we're crazy sorry
sorry
and let's let's go to warsaw for some
final thoughts of an exciting day too
chris
guys uh i don't know what you guys are
talking about our predictions are pretty
terrible i mean nobody picked vichy and
nobody picked the richard the top two
contenders uh going into the final day
of rapid that's uh not great anyway an
amazing day filled with exciting a chess
four draws in the last one but still
very combative draws and it's amazing to
see the youngsters finally making some
noise in this one and uh vichy the tiger
of madras is still roaring going into
the last day of rapid is going to be an
amazing day anastasia what uh did you
see today yeah actually the same i'm
very happy that uh kirill shivchenko and
david gabrielesko are back to the
tournament they already made a couple of
draws i'm expecting they will do even
better tomorrow um of course as someone
who's obsessed with numbers i paid
attention that we had seven decisive
games today
so still some not bad at all of course a
little bit less than yesterday but
they're still wearing a good track so
i'm looking forward for more exciting
games tomorrow it's going to be the last
round the last day of the rapid chess
and i think everybody will fight really
hard
last day before the action gets fast
even faster and more furious as we enter
the blitz portion guys a lot of exciting
chess ahead back to you
thank you christian thank you and
anastasia i felt that christian just put
us in our place
it wasn't necessarily
necessary though you guys are terrible i
mean
telling it the way it is
that's what it's all about as long as
he's not wrong
he allowed him is right right yes very
much alejandro final thoughts of a very
eventful day two it was a great day you
see vichy roaring it's always a good day
i love seeing rickard coming back from a
terrible tournament in bucharest and
finding his strike today winning three
in a row is going to put tons of wins
behind his sales this is gonna be a fun
event tomorrow we have a great day of
rapid finishing up with three rounds i'm
excited for tomorrow and we're bright
and early here in st louis to call the
action i'm
very excited alejandra thank you very
much i think that put it in perspective
and really uh peter alejandro anastasia
and christian it's been great calling
the action and thanks to the players for
making it so much fun thank you for
joining us and sharing your day we'll
see you tomorrow same time and same
channel see you then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited